Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Datenspende App wurden identifiziert und mit entsprechenden Empfehlungen dokumentiert. Okay gucken wir mal
Nintendo wurde wohl gehackt echt haben wir nicht gesehen
Interessant
Und
Gibt es auch was beheißen oder so
Okay, also was was ist was ist nintendo hack
Hast du schon gehört dass ein half life alex mod gibt für maus keyboard
Ne habe ich nicht aber das ist so ein spiel das will ich gar nicht 2d mit maus und tastatur spielen
Okay, also nintendo wurde gehackt ist das so das wusste ich noch gar nicht
War warum was was wie
Bla bla bla
2 step verification habe ich nicht an auf mein nintendo account
Wobei kann das sein dass man kann man muss man nicht sogar 2 2 faktor authentifizierung einschalten sobald man was bezahlen will
Man braucht den google authenticator um mit nintendo also nintendo kriegt auch nix selbst auf die reihe, oder
Warum können die warum können die keine warum können die keine
Zumindest mal sms oder oder irgendwie andere message
identifizierung machen
Ich meine die billigste form von
2 step authentifizierung
Machen ich meine die billigste form von 2 step authentifizierung ist immer noch du kriegst ein email geschickt du musst dann auf den link klingen
Ein bot what the fuck aber schon ewig nimmer
euch kack nu jetzt habe ich jetzt habe ich die nachricht gelöscht aber ihn nicht geblockt
Mods könnt ihr das machen den typ blocken
Sehr gut ja die wissen bescheid wie es geht
Ok also das heißt ich muss mir mal aufschreiben nachher muss ich mal gucken ob mein nintendo
account 2 step
Authentification hat oder zumindest irgendwas keine ahnung die ganze ganze krepp immer da sind wir wieder beim thema wir hatten vorhin was mit
oder gestern was mit
Passwort apps und ganz ehrlich wenn man sowas sieht wollte wirklich eure passwörter online in einer passwort app speichern
Ich sag ich sag nix dagegen dass sie den google authenticator verwenden man könnte aber einfach mehrere sachen anbieten
Alle mal besser als einfach nur passwort t-max electronics drei monate. Ja ja ja
Subscriber
Muss ich mir nachher mal gucken was damit nintendo los ist so jetzt wollen wir uns mal gucken was das
Was der chaos computer klub über die corona app rausgekriegt hat also folgende sicherheit wir lesen uns jetzt nicht alles durch wir gucken uns die zusammenfassung an also sprich das hier
Also folgende sicherheitsmängel der corona datenspende app wurden identifiziert und empfehlungen geben also was ist der erste punkt fitness daten
Werden regelmäßig nicht vom smart phone des datenspenders aus anders
RKI übermittelt sondern vom robert-koch-institut direkt beim anbieter des fitness trackers oder google fit abgefragt
Ist gar nicht dass es überhaupt geht
Und erst anschließend pseudonymisiert ja das ist das ist schon mal bescheuert
Ich meine ich kann mir vorstellen warum sie es machen dass sie das irgendwie die die übertragten
Dass sie das irgendwie die über ganz einfacher von einem von einem anbieter was abrufen wie
Von der smart phone vom smartphone das smartwatch sachen die übertragen lassen
Aber allein schon im sinne des datenschutzes wäre es sinnvoller
Das vom gerät direkt übertragen zu lassen und gleich zu anonymisieren bei der übertragung zumal und das ist ja der nächste punkt
Hier speichern sie die zugangsdaten
Müssen sie ja sonst können sie wahrscheinlich an die api nicht dran da sieht man schon wieder der nächste fail
war also rückte euren kram nicht raus
Wer programmiert den kram eigentlich immer
Also hierzu speichert das robert-koch-institut zugangsdaten mit denen unter anderem auf die vollständige fitness historie
Und die namen der datenspender zugegriffen werden kann
exzellent
Gibt genug leute den ist das burscht
Ja, also sieht man man sieht es ja an allen ecken und enden dass die leute verkehrt das hat eh schon jeder meine daten was juckt mich
ok
Jeder wie er will
Ich habe das schon oft genug was zu gesagt wie ich das denke aber im endeffekt jeder wie er will jeder muss gucken
Wo mit seinem kram was er mit seinem kram macht die möglichkeit
Datenspender unter missbrauch dieser zugangsdaten direkt zu identifizieren hebelt den zweck der pseudonymisierung aus ja logisch
Da kann man sich das auch fast gleich sparen
Choose manem wahrscheinlich allerdings müssen sie das ja trotzdem machen
Wenn sie es direkt beim anpeter des fitness trackers oder bei google fit abfragen
Da müssen sie zumindest mal 20 fitness tracker apis und google fit unterstützen
Was auch immer und machen was sie wollen
Ich kann verstehen dass man sie macht
Sicher ist es nicht so es ist
beabsichtigt aus den analyseergebnissen der fitness daten lokale maßnahmen zur eindämmung
Corona pandemie abzuleihen das einfache einbringen falsche fitness daten erlaubt jedoch eine gezielte beeinflusse dieser maßnahme
Da haben sie nicht unrecht da habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht also sprich wenn ich jetzt mannig mannig mannig ich möchte manipulieren
Was da als ergebnis rauskommt könnte ich einfach sinnlose schwachsinn verbreiteten
Könnte ich einfach sinnlose schwachsinn fitness daten pushen ok habe ich es nicht dran gedacht ergibt aber auch irgendwie sinn
Bei verknüpfung der app mit einem fitness tracker müssen dass ein zugangs daten eingegeben werden
In der mehrzahl der fälle können diese durch mannende mittel angreifer mitgelesen werden das ist natürlich doof
Zugangs daten können zum beispiel bei verlust oder diebstahl des smartphones durch dritte gestohlen werden ja gut das
Ist ja meistens so also kommt drauf an bei iphone eher weniger
Und bei android je nachdem was die leute installiert haben das heißt ja aber vielen sachen das ist jetzt wirklich nicht unbedingt so
spezifisch für diese app
Der server das rki
exponiert zusätzliche
Funktionalität wie ein management und admin interface what the fuck warum
Ok das ist das ist schon massive massive pepega
Warum macht man warum macht man admin und management interfaces ins internet
Warum macht man sowas wie kommt man auf die idee dass das eine gute idee ist
Was so wie so wie eine soap api was ist denn mit denen los
Die sind auch 1998 stehen geblieben oder
Moment was war das gerade für eine musik genau das war tales of symphony ja kommt man kam irgendwie übelst bekannt vor
Also das ist naja so
Es ist nach api meinetwegen können sie machen wie sie wollen das so richtig modern ist es nicht das hier ist aber das das viel größere problem
management und admin interface im internet das heißt nicht zwangsläufig dass es unsicher ist aber
Sie schreiben es ja auch hier dass die an das du viel mehr angreiffläche hast dadurch dass es im internet hängt
Musikliste ich kann da keine musikliste erstellen das ist eine fünf stunden
Das ist eine fünf stunden youtube video. Das ist keine playlist
Also eine playlist wo ich nicht weiß welche lieder was sind
Aber wenn du wissen willst hier das da ist es hier top 1000 in tenno songs of all-time
400 bis 301 ok was kommt als nächstes noch kenntnis des pseudonyms eines datenspenders
Erlaubt dritten dessen verknüpfung mit einem fitness trecker einzusehen oder zu manipulieren das ist natürlich schon mal super
Das ist natürlich schon mal ganz doll
Zudem besteht die gefahr dass dritte darüber ansprüche inklusive
Das ist natürlich schon mal ganz doll zudem besteht die gefahr dass dritte darüber ansprüche inklusive
Recht auf einsicht gemäß die sg vor
Hier war so immer aber das ist schon mal dumm
Also sprich wenn du irgendein nickname kennst von jemanden der die app verwendet kannst du wohl die daten seines fitness treckers einsehen das schon mal fail
Das ist schon mal fail
Moon moon subs
Zudem sind die anforderungen eine wirksame einwilligung zur verarbeitung von gesundheit daten nach dsg gut das wäre mir persönlich jetzt ziemlich wurscht
Aber der dsg vo weiß ja eh keiner so genau wann wie was ab welcher stelle legal ist und war nicht
Okay, der rest gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an ich wollte bloß mal kurz zu drüber gucken
Wenn ihr schon irgendwelche körl auf rufe siehst die ist
Gut
Zumindest scheint das ding nicht sonderlich sicher zu sein und man kann wohl nur jedem abraten diese corona app zu verwenden
Ist wieder der wahnsinn ich frage mich bei sowas immer wer den kram programmiert
Die werden sich selbst machen die werden das irgendwo beauftragen aber die kombination aus so grundlegenden
schwachstellen und einer soap api im internet inklusive admin und management interfaces
Gibt grund zu der annahme dass es nicht die größten leuchten auf dieser erde sind die das ganze programmieren
Die fitness trecker app ist relativ unwichtig die große wenn die fitness trecker app schon so im arsch ist da will ich gar nicht wissen was mit der großen app bloß ist
Ich kenne nur die soap im fernsehen ja für alle dies nicht kennen ich ich schock euch mal ich zeige euch mal ein beispiel von der soap xml api
Gibt bestimmt gibt es bestimmt schöne jetzt bestimmt schöne beispiele auf wie man die sobalen sobalen sobalen sobalen sobalen sobalen sobalen sobalen sobalen sobalen sobalen sobalen sobalen sobalen sobalen
Jetzt bestimmt schöne beispiel auf wikipedia oder so
Ja hier ist jetzt schöne beispiel von der soap api
Da wird ganz viel xml
Hin und her geschickt bei so bei so prequest das hat man so 2000 rum gemacht so 95
95 bis 2005 oder so ist einfach mal so aus dem bauch rausgesagt in dem tri hat man das gemacht
Und ihr könnt euch vorstellen xml ist ja nur selten kurz
In dem fall ist es ein kurzes beispiel die eigentlichen soap requests die sind fünf seiten lang
Das will man eigentlich nicht haben
Und es ist echt das ist eine wissenschaft für sich
Es sagt schon alles dass die alte api von dhl noch über xml soap funktioniert
Die neue mittlerweile nicht mehr aber so die die die stable dhl api
Die man auch als erstes unter google findet die funkt verwendet auch noch xml soap
Solar war jetzt kommt aber hier die crap software anstarrter solar winds n central verwendet auch soap ap musste damit arbeiten
Wir haben ein system bei uns auf der arbeit
das hat eine ganz tolle taktik was api angeht das ist so ein so ein
ein zentrales verwaltungstool wo alle alle hardware alle server alle api adressen alle
Einzelteile und und domains und so ein ding wo alles zentral drin verwaltet wird
Und das ist ein tool das ist die oberfläche ist schon absolut mega für den arsch kann sie euch mal zeigen
Glaubt das ist die alte version davon
Ich muss euch mal guck mal also wenn du schon mal bei einem anbieter keine screenshots von der oberfläche findest da weißt du schon mal
Bescheid dass es kacke ist ich versuche ich mal ein paar bilder von zu zeigen
Ja hier
Wer so eine kacke programmiert das ist oberflächen design von 2001
Da fuck guckt euch das mal an
Ja da fuck guckt euch das mal an
Ja so sieht das scheiß aus guckt es euch an es ist für stelle ich
Es ist absolut für genauso sieht der kram aus es ist absolut es ist absolut für stelle ich es ist optimiert für den microsoft internet explorer aber
Es funktioniert auch glücklicherweise in anderen browser
So und die haben es ganz besonders toll gemacht die haben es ganz besonders toll gemacht mit ihrer api
Die haben
Einen api guide der ist 25 seiten das ist eigentlich auch ganz gut
Aber die haben ihre api 20 mal umgestellt in der vergangenheit immer auf das was hip war deswegen läuft es jetzt so dass man
alles über htp post requests macht man macht sogar das ausloggen sogar das logout
Über den post requests
Man macht alles über htp post requests und
Der inhalt von den requests
Bestes das ist jason mit embedded xml sowas habt ihr noch nicht gesehen das ist jason mit embedded xml
Ja das sieht dann ungefähr so aus
Mal exemplarisch mal so beispielsweise also da hast du dann hier so ein jason dokument
War mal hier kurz jason
Ja jason hast du irgendwie sowas wie keine ahnung server
Keine ahnung
Production irgendwas keine ahnung steht da drin so und dann hast du unten filter da kannst du filter eingeben
Filter so normalerweise es muss man ja sagen was da gefiltert werden soll
So und dieses diese diese diese query filter engine unten drunter ist wahrscheinlich noch so alt
Die stammt noch aus der zeit wo man sow prequest gemacht hat deswegen brauchst du da jetzt so brauchst du dann so ein so ein so ein
Ding wie irgendwie search node
Look ab
Blob search node
Irgendwie so in der richtung ja ist
Ich vermeide das ich frage mich
Ja ist ich vermeide das ich frage einfach alles aber ab und fehlt das dann danach
Look ab und dann machst du danach irgendwie noch noch irgendwie
Filter name
Contains das ist dann so ein ding am ende das ist das ist quasi
jason mit embedded xml
responses dann jammel
Das muss ich dir mal vorschlagen das machen die wahrscheinlich auch
Warum warum höre ich mein kopfhörer nur auf einer seite was da los
Warum jetzt excellent excellent max hat gewusst
Ich sage
Das ist wahnsinnig big brain
Bus die da gemacht haben die findest du eigentlich metro schrecklich
Absolut schrecklich finde ich ruckelt das stream leute ruckelt das stream
Nö meine vorschau ruckelt aber das stream ruckelt nicht
Meine vorschau pepega vorschau ruckelt
Ich brauche keine vorschau solange es nicht ruckelt alles gut
So also metro finde ich absolut absolut schrecklich
Kachelgeschichten muss echt nicht sein
Auch wenn ich kein apple fan bin ich muss sagen so rein
Ui mäßig wenn man so die ausmahl hat es gibt ja es gibt ja so drei
Es gibt ja so drei drei große dinge es gibt diese microsoft
Nennen wir es mal ursprünglich was metro danach war es flat flat design
Gedöns weiß ich gar nicht mehr wie es hieß und jetzt ist es glaube ich
Nee
Wie heißt das jetzt von microsoft
Die name die kann man sich alle nennen
Die name die kann man sich alle merken
Fluent fluent design es ist jetzt fluent design ok also man hat also diese drei sachen hat diese microsoft fluent fluent design geschichte
Dann hast du material
Material design von google und hast das
Das
Wie heißt das von apple
Dieses apple design halt
So und wenn ich die auswahl dazwischen habe muss ich ehrlich sagen
Das apple design
Rein von der benutzbarkeit her wenn wir jetzt mal von von von mobile reden gefällt mir persönlich am besten
Und auch auf dem desktop ist mir das am liebsten
Wobei ich sagen muss dass ich halt apple als plattform also dass ich mac os als plattform nicht sonderlich gerne habe
Wenn ich video kram und und spielen will nehme ich windows für alles andere nehme ich linux also ich habe eigentlich gar keinen großartigen
Anwendungszweck aktuell für mac es gibt ein paar programe die ich gerne
Und der mac os verwenden würde aber dafür noch extra ein mac os rechner hinstellen ist eigentlich
Windows 10 ist fluent design allerdings
So wie das bei microsoft halt ist nicht durchgängig nicht durchgängig also zum beispiel der taschenrechner
Der ist fluent design sieht übrigens pot hässlich aus das ding an der stelle
Das ist fluent design allerdings nicht alles weil alte anwendungen zum beispiel sind entweder noch ganz klassisches uralt
win 32
gdi sonst wie gedöns
oder so ein hybrid so ein hybrid ding
aus
win 32
win 32 mit mit
Wie heißen die kraken wie heißt der kram hier aber noch mal ribbons ribbons und sowas also bei cross off ist ganz wir
Wirklich ganz ganz wir
Die mischung da draussen das neueste design prinzip ist halt quasi bei microsoft fluent design da stellen sie ihre eigenen sachen immer mehr drauf um
Leider sind die die in windows 10 mitgelieferten apps zum größten teil absoluter crap
Da war outlook express besser als das windows 10 mailprogramm und das heißt schon was
So deswegen
Ich finde das prinzipiell gut was microsoft hier gemacht hat mit fluent design da gibt es auch ein schönes video zu
Von der idee her ist das gut das ist eines der wenigen designs die auch schöne schöne farbverläufe und kontraste haben
ich
google material design finde ich hat auch schöne kontraste aber alles andere sie an material design so aus als hat das einer
Mit pain zusammen gewusstet also ich bin überhaupt kein fan von von material design obwohl ich selbst
Und die letzten web anwendungen selbst mit material design gemacht habe
Weil es cross platform halt gut akzeptiert ist mir gefällt es nicht
Das sieht man schon daran mal nur so ein vergleich kennt ihr alle den time picker von ios
Den hat glaube ich jeder zumindest schon mal gesehen das ist der time picker von ios oder date date time picker von ios
Also sprich das kreuz die hier so durch
Das ist das ist quasi so ein rundes rad so ein bisschen wie die hardstone matchmaking suche
Kennt ihr ja das kreut man dann hoch
Und dann
Kennt jemand von euch den standard
Google material design date time picker das ist der hier also mal ganz im ernst
Wer um alles in der welt bei google ist auf die glorreiche idee gekommen dass das ein guter
Denk geht der time picker ist, aber da blickt auch keine sau durch
Es ich finde es ist es könnte auch ein bisschen
Es könnte auch ein bisschen kokona style sein dass die gedacht haben wer braucht da schon 24 zeichen drauf
Die dachten die haben wahrscheinlich gedacht ey man braucht doch bloß bis 12 und dann ist gut
Das das das das die minuten kommen danach das kommt ja auch noch dabei also sprich du will ich kann euch kann ich mal ein beispiel zeigen
Ja ich zeige euch mal ein beispiel
Von material design date ane ich muss ich nicht date picker time picker
Time picker so das ist das ist nachgebauter material design time picker so am p.m.
So und du schaltest hier oben zwischen minuten und und stunden um wir brauchen mal 24 stunden design haben die hier in 24 stunden design drin
Also das ist schon mal komplett cancer wenn ich mir das hier angucken also du brauchst dann
Keine ahnung
Und dann schaltet er um auf minuten
Und dann schaltet er um auf minuten ich werde fack was ist das?
Das ist zum kotzen das kriege ich anfälle wenn ich sowas sehe also ich finde es nicht schön
Ich lasse gelten ich habe das im chat schon gesehen
Ich lasse gelten wenn man sagt dass wenn man geübt ist dass es schneller geht
Ich lasse ich irgendwo gelten wenn man sich wirklich dran gewöhnt hat allerdings finde ich die die mentale überlastung
Die man hat wenn erst mal dieser date time picker auf ploppt
Die ist es die ist es nicht wert
Da wo da bist du erst mal zehn sekunden verwirrt
Wenn du den date time picker auf auf auf ploppt weil wir natürlich auch da nicht einheitlich sind mit zwölf stunden 24 stunden
Du bist erst mal zehn sekunden verwirrt bis du durch blickst
Da gefällt mir der hier wirklich umlängen besser
Und ihr wisst ich bin kein großer apple fan aber das kriegen die besser hin zumal das feeling auf einem touch gerät auch viel schöner ist
Jetzt ist schaumparty besucher kann wie gesagt ich kann nichts dagegen sagen wenn das persönliche der persönliche
Geschmack eben dass einer besser findet aber
Für mich ist das hier viel viel angenehmer vor allem du kannst auch viel schöner auf einem
Auf einem touch gerät hier durch scrollen
Als dass du hier durch scrollen kannst man könnte sagen hier muss ich nicht durch scrollen hier kann ich direkt drauf touchen
Aber ich finde es persönlich viel einfacher hier wenn ich sage ok ich brauche jetzt viel uhr dass ich aber mit dem finger nach oben hab
Hier finde ich viel viel angenehmer als dieses dieses ding hier so
Bisschen geschmackssache ist natürlich dabei
Aber wer auch immer bei google auf die idee gekommen ist dass dieses default ding
Die beste wahl ist die einem einfällt für den date time picker dann weiß ich auch nicht
Als dingy so schlimm
Als das die einzige beautify komponente ist die ich nicht verwende weil ich keinem zu muten will
Da drüber eine uhrzeit auszuwählen
Ja
So viel genug zum zum rant über date time picker weiß man nicht ob wir da drauf gekommen sind
Er hat irgendwie irgendwelche gründen von nintendo
sachen
Lieber einen slider klar slider beste
Auch so ein ding was ich bei material design komisch finde ist
Buttons
Dass der button nicht gedrückt wird sondern dass der button quasi dass der button quasi
Rauskommt als anstatt rein geht wenn man draufklickt ist auch so eine so eine sache die ich erst mal ein bisschen verwirrend finde
Ansonsten was ich bei material design gut finde ist dass es eben breit akzeptiert ist mittlerweile
Also sprich material design oder material ist ein ist quasi das neue bootstrap
Wo früher seiten alle anwendungen seiten web also web seiten alle möglichen anwendungen haben es nachgemacht waren alle bootstrap
heute sind die meisten material
Was ich gut finde wenn die leute sich an was gewöhnt haben
Weil dann muss nicht jeder sich was eigenes aus den fingern saugen und du wirst auch nicht blöd angeguckt zu achten oder wie sieht
Dann deine anwendung aus machte material design auch wenn das selbst nicht schön findest aber die leute sind wenigstens zufrieden
So mal kurz gucken was wir noch ein paar fragen haben
Bist du gespannt auf das neue surface book 3 nee ehrlich gesagt nicht ich habe mich damit auch nicht beschäftigt ich habe auch kein surface book
Soll ja wohl eine der wenigen microsoft hardware sein wo die leute die bude einrennen
Welche mac programe sind das also ich kann es jetzt gerade gar nicht mehr ganz aktuell sagen weil ich habe mich schon eine weile nicht
mehr mit beschäftigt das waren ursprünglich war das omni krefel
Die to do app die glaube ich einfach auch to do heißt
Dann dass es jede menge
Programme mit khaldaf und khaldaf support für mac gibt die es halt irgendwie überall anders nicht richtig funktioniert
Ziemlich schwierig wenn man sich mal vergleicht thunderbird mit khaldaf integration wenn man das mit einem ordentlichen
Programm unter mac vergleicht ist das schon sehr schon welten dazwischen da gibt es richtig gute richtig gute to do apps und kalender
Und wo das schön integriert ist das ist ja unter lehnungs und windows
wahnsinnig
schlimm
Was waren das andere noch was ich verwenden wollte
Gar nicht mehr zusammen
Aber nichts wichtiges also nichts ist so wichtig dass ich sagen würde dafür lohnt sich das noch extra weggen zu stellen
Kannst du kennst du eine gute empfehlung wie man einen esp 32 einrichtet installieren
Beim esp 32 ist nicht so viel mit einrichten und installieren das ist eigentlich was was dafür gedacht ist dass du selbst programmierst
Also das ist eher eine plattform wo du dir selbst was zusammenbauen kannst was du willst also sprich du holst den esp 32 bord
Du holst dir paar sensoren was du messen willst und dann musst du halt musst du ja wissen was du damit machen willst
Es gibt ein paar fertige sachen kannst du das motor nehmen zum beispiel
Das ist eine fertige firme für esp 866 ich weiß gar nicht auf die oft läuft die auf dem esp 32
wahrscheinlich
Dies ganz gut du kannst wenn du es nicht so sehr mit c oder pice also nicht so richtig hardcore mit programmierungen
Hast ist esp home auch ziemlich gut
Das sind alles firmwares für den esp 32 und esp 866 die dir viel arbeit abnehmen
Ja also der hat also das hier finde ich richtig gut für leute die eben nicht
So die großen programmierer die großen programmierprose sind
Das motor für kleine sachen die einfach
Was ein und ausschalten sollen ist das gut? Wenn du wirklich was brauchst custom für dich
unterschiedliche entsorgen dann nehm esp home
Allerdings ich bin davon weggekommen jetzt ich habe ja mal ein paar sachen mit esp home ausgerüstet
Aber im nachhinein hat es das für mich komplizierter gemacht als einfach den kram weiter selbst zu machen
Selbst programmieren hat den vorteil man weiß wirklich genau was das ding macht und wenn man eine gewisse logik braucht
Die man die man ja oftmals wenn man eine hardware mit sensoren hat braucht man ja eine gewisse logik dahinter
Man möchte in so und so in einem intervall was schicken man möchte die daten die man vom sensor bekommt so und so aufbereiten
Um sie dann weiter zu verschicken
Das ist eben so dass man sich die daten in so und so in so und so in so und so aufbereiten
Zu verschicken das ist eh individuell für das was man machen will und ich finde es einfacher die logik direkt in c zu programmieren
Als in einem jammel dialekt oder so
So so viel so viel da dazu
Das hatten wir das ist von gestern
Boah so viel zeug alles nicht gelöscht
Das wird nicht verguckt hier mal den aktuellen markt an so viel arbeit so okay ich weiß kann ich weiß nicht mehr um was es dagegen
Was bei uns gibt es immer montags die termine für die woche vergibt so zwanzig prozent hat er mir sind für kontrolle
Da gibt es immer wieder das kund hinkriegen
Dein meme tut brauche noch die tanzen afrikaner mit sagen nee wozu die habe ich heute morgen erst wieder gesehen auf twitter hat
Irgendjemand gepostet
Zwanzig zwanzig euro irgendwie in dem dreh
Das hatten wir gestern schon aus das hatten wir gestern schon ausführlich beantwortet
Das hatten wir gestern schon ausführlich beantwortet
So Leute wir haben alle fragen beantwortet oder die leitknopf seht ihr den delete das der delete knopf ist verbuckt
Das fixen wir jetzt aber nicht. Wir machen jetzt mal ein bisschen C++, dass ich mich ein bisschen beschweren kann wieder.
So, wo sind wir denn gestern schön stehen geblieben?
Also nochmal kurz hier die Übersicht verschaffen.
Handle Error, bla. Achja, ist der Patrick schon da?
Der Patrick wollte ja in der Library nach dem Bug suchen, warum wir hier einen Restart machen müssen.
Ich habe heute morgen auch mal kurz nebenbei ein bisschen geschaut. Ich glaube, ich weiß an welcher Stelle das liegt.
Was das wird? Also, ich erzähle es nochmal ganz kurz. Kann ich eigentlich immer am Anfang des Streams nochmal kurz recapen?
Moment, wo sind die Bilder? Ich hatte doch die Bilder eben.
Wo sind die Bilder? Ich hatte eben die Bilder. Ich habe sie doch eben gerade noch gesehen.
Hier, Post. Da ist es.
Also, das ist mein Gegensprechanlagen-Telefon von der Tür-Gegensprechanlage.
Und das ist ein Tablet. Das sieht man. Tab-Organisation.
So, und was ich da eingebaut habe ist, ich habe so einen kleinen Tiny Pico ESP32 da eingebaut.
Hier sieht man es schöner. Der ist ungefähr ein bisschen größer wie so ein Daumennagel. Die Dinger sind wirklich klein.
Das ist aber ein vollwertiger ESP32. Du siehst den Vergleich zur Batterie.
Und da habe ich einen davon hinter diesem Telefon drin stecken.
Und der erkennt, wann es klingelt und wann jemand den Hörer abgenommen hat.
Natürlich wäre es gut, das Ding ist ja da fest installiert, wenn man das über das WLAN updaten könnte.
Und irgendwie habe ich mir in den Kopf gesetzt, ich möchte das Ding über WLAN, allerdings über HTTPS updaten.
Es ist überhaupt gar kein Problem, den ESP32 zu updaten.
Da gibt es sogar schon fix und fertige Sachen über HTTPS. Überhaupt kein Ding.
Ist auch total easy selbst programmiert.
Über HTTPS ist eine andere Hausnummer. Da gibt es schlicht und ergreifend nichts fertiges zu.
Deswegen machen wir das selbst. Aber wir machen das nicht ganz blind.
Ich habe mir im Vorfeld schon ein bisschen was überlegt und ein bisschen was aufgeschrieben, was wir machen können.
Wir sind gestern stehen geblieben. Wenn ich das richtig sehe, wir haben einen Web-Server gestartet.
Ich muss mal übrigens den ESP gerade connecten, den sehe ich hier. Der ist gar nicht dran.
Wo ist mein ESP? Ah, hier.
Da ist er.
Connect. Ah, yes.
Also, wo wir stehen geblieben sind, ist, wir haben, wir generieren beim Starten vom ESP ein neues Self-Signed SSL-Zertifikat.
Was lustigerweise funktioniert, was bei mir nie funktioniert hat, aber gestern im Stream hat es funktioniert.
Den connecten wir einfach über USB. Ja, den connectest du über USB oder aber du kannst halt danach über WLAN updaten.
Über HTTP gar kein Problem, über HTTPS ist das schwierig.
Also, du kannst den über USB connecten und quasi initial deinen Programmer hochladen.
Wenn du den dann halt irgendwo hinter der Wand eingebaut hast, keine Ahnung, an der Haustür eingebaut hast, dann ist halt doof mit USB anschließen.
Deswegen muss man das Ding auch über das WLAN updaten können.
Was ist ein ESP? ESP ist ein Microcontroller. Gibt es mehrere von, von einem chinesischen Hersteller.
Wo kommt, oder südkoreanisch? Wo kommt Espressif her?
Shanghai.
China. Oder China, wie die coolen Leute sagen.
Aus China.
Das sind Microcontroller von einem chinesischen Hersteller. Die gibt es in zwei Varianten. Einmal als ESP866 und als ESP32.
Die ESP32 ist die Dualcore Variante und die auch schneller ist und viel mehr Features hat.
Da gibt es ein Plugin für, für, für vias Code. Ja, es gibt Platform.io nennt sich das.
Das ist eine komplette IDE für alles was ESP zeugs und Arduino und alles mögliche.
Dadurch, dass die halt sehr viel unterstützen, ist es nicht immer so, nicht immer wahnsinnig schnell die letzte Softwareversion.
Die brauchen auch manchmal irgendwie ein, zwei Monaten bis es updaten.
Espressif lieber liefert aber doch nur das Layout. Ich weiß nicht wer die eigentlich in Chips herstellt.
Die Boards machen auf jeden Fall mehrere Hersteller.
Also der ESP82 ist ja nur quasi der Chip mit CPU und Bluetooth und Gedöns drauf.
Die Boards an sich machen andere Hersteller.
Es gibt zum Beispiel das Board hier. Dann gibt es noch die größere Variante.
Dieses Node, Node MCU Ding hier. Die gibt es noch. Die sind eigentlich relativ beliebt.
Die sind ein bisschen größer. Hast du die Pins schon vorher installiert? Also schon draufgelötet. Musste gar nichts mehr machen.
Es gibt auch noch andere richtig nice Boards. Zum Beispiel der hier.
Der ESP32 Fire Beetle. Sieht zwar auf den ersten Blick mal so aus wie jedes ESP82 Board.
Allerdings das coole an dem ist, dass das, also erstmal hat es einen Batterie-Connector.
Kriegt man aber andere Boards auch ohne Probleme dran.
Aber es ist für Batteriebetrieb ausgelegt. Und das verbraucht so gut wie nichts im Standby.
Die haben es nämlich hier mal richtig gemacht.
Wenn das Ding über Batterie betrieben wird, schaltet er alles aus.
Alle Spannungswandler für USB, alles was man nicht irgendwie braucht, schaltet er aus.
Das heißt er verbraucht im Deep Sleep verbraucht der Fire Beetle bloß glaube ich 11 µA oder so in dem Dreh.
Also fast nichts.
Wenn ihr das Ding nur ab und zu mal, wenn ihr das Ding nur ein paar mal am Tag aufwachen lässt,
um irgendwelche Bodenfeuchtigkeit, Temperatur oder was auch immer zu übertragen,
dann hält ihr das Ding zwei Jahre an einer normalen Batterie.
Also mit einer normalen Batterie meinst du mal ein Akku, keine Batterie.
Ja 11 µA ist nicht wenig, das stimmt.
Aber für ein Ding mit Onboard WLAN, Onboard Bluetooth, Dual Core 240 MHz, Low Power 8 MHz Core,
also von den Features her gibt es da schon.
Und es gibt auch gar nicht mal so viel andere, die Feature mäßig auch nur ansatzweise mithalten könnten,
die in den Regionen sind.
Mir wird es ja schon reichen, wenn du da irgendwie was per Funk oder so übertragen könntest.
Also ich kenne da nicht so viele, die da...
Habe ich mich mit µA jetzt vielleicht vertan?
Warte mal, ne ne ich ziemlich sicher µA.
SP32, Deep Sleep.
Ich habe es gemessen, ich glaube es waren 11 µA.
Warte mal, 0,05.
Das ist jetzt aber mA, oder?
Ja, 10 µA im Deep Sleep.
Zum Beispiel auf dem Friedhof, ja das stimmt.
Auf dem Friedhof habe ich einen Fire Beetle 32 stehen.
Habe ich nicht wirklich.
Ich habe gebated, also ich habe einen gebaut dafür, aber der steht gerade nicht da.
Hat das schon mal jemand versucht?
Ne, ich kann es mir mal angucken.
Der steht gar nicht da, aber ich habe das nie fertig gemacht.
Real Vim in Visual Studio Code, ne habe ich nicht probiert.
Mir haben die bisherigen Vim Plugins für Visual Studio Code auch überhaupt nicht gefallen, weil die alle so geleckt haben.
Und falls jetzt irgendjemand fragt, warum ich auf einem Friedhof einen ESP32 hatte bzw. wieder haben werde, liegt das da dran.
Muss ich mal kurz ausholen.
Ich habe einen Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor.
Keinen davon, den da habe ich.
Den da.
Da habe ich hier oben einen Schrumpfschlauch drum gemacht.
Um die Elektronik.
Und ein bisschen, was ist das, so ein Spray drüber gemacht.
Dass quasi die Elektronik nicht komplett rostet und kaputt geht.
Und das Ding ist an einem ESP32 dran.
Und das ist auf dem Friedhof, das heißt ich bekomme immer mit, wann ich auf den Friedhof fahren muss und gieße.
Zum Gießen.
Ich kriege live, naja mit ein paar Stunden Verzögerung, einfach in Harz eingießen.
Ja, das ist sowas.
Das ist so Harz, das ist so eine Art Harz.
Das ist irgendwas zum Sprayen.
Ich habe mir extra bei Amazon so eine Dose gekauft.
Ich glaube, das ist irgend so ein Harz.
Zum Spraysoren.
So und das, der Plan ist, dass ich das wieder auf den Friedhof bringe, weil da steht es ja aktuell nicht.
Und das überträgt dann die Daten vom Friedhof zu mir heim.
Und das funktioniert, das funktioniert.
Der Friedhof ist ungefähr, ungefähr 1,1 Kilometer weg.
Und da werde ich euch jetzt natürlich fragen, wie möchte man 1,1 Kilometer Daten übertragen?
Das ist ja ganz schön weit weg.
Da habt ihr recht, das ist ganz schön weit weg.
Deswegen mache ich das auch nicht per WLAN und ich habe da auch keinen Mobilfunk oder sowas drinne.
Das mache ich mit LoRa auf 868 Megahertz.
Genau.
Mit so einem Modul und so einer Antenne, so einer kleinen Antenne.
Und das Einzige, was da rausguckt an der Erde, am Grab, ist tatsächlich die Antenne.
Und ihr werdet nicht glauben, wie gut das funktioniert.
1,1 Kilometer Übertragung.
Ich habe es natürlich, das haben wir sogar mal im Stream gemacht, oder?
Haben wir das nicht sogar mal im Stream zusammen ausprobiert?
Die Übertragung ist sehr langsam.
Also wirklich sehr langsam.
Wir reden da von Bytes und noch nicht mal pro Sekunde.
Also keine Ahnung, ich sage jetzt einfach mal, ich habe fast das langsamste eingestellt, was geht.
Das sind dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ich sage jetzt einfach mal 20 Bytes in 5 Sekunden oder so.
Die Übertragung ist wirklich langsam, aber sie geht 1,1 Kilometer.
Und für ein bisschen Sensordaten ist es auch vollkommen egal, ob das Ding so lang braucht oder nicht.
Was soll das auf dem Friedhof machen?
Das war ja schon mal auf dem Friedhof.
Das misst die Bodenfeuchtigkeit, also wie nass die Erde ist, am Grab von meinem Opa und meiner Oma.
Das Glück gehabt, dass sich keiner beim Buddel auf dem Friedhof erwischt. Warum? Ich darf da auch Blumen ein und ausgraben, das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Das ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Oh, beste Outro Musik.
Das ist nicht Mario 64.
Ist das nicht die Mario 64 Credits und nicht Mario Kart 64 Credits?
Warte da, bis ich die 5G Fraktion sehe.
Ja, ich werde es jetzt erstmal ausprobieren.
So viel dazu. Wir machen jetzt erstmal ein bisschen weiter.
Also, wir sind hier stehen geblieben, wir generieren uns beim Start vom ESP ein Zertifikat.
Ein Fake Zertifikat natürlich.
Gucken, ob das geklappt hat. Mit dem Zertifikat generieren wir nicht. Also, vorher machen wir WLAN an.
Und, dass ich mein Passwort nicht leake, habe ich das hier in der extra Datei ausgelagert.
Wir machen WLAN an, generieren ein Zertifikat, gucken, ob das Zertifikatgenerieren geklappt hat.
Dann starten wir den Webserver.
Also, auf Port 443 SSL.
Und dann unterhalb der Route slash Update registrieren wir uns die Funktion, wo dann unser Firmware Update hingeschickt wird.
Also sprich, wenn ich ein Firmware Update hochlade, also das ist die IP, die der Controller kriegt im WLAN.
Wenn ich ein Firmware Update hochlade, dann kommt das in dieser Methode raus.
Und ich kann es auf den Flash vom Controller schreiben.
So, soweit sind wir aktuell.
Und jetzt probieren wir nochmal aus, wo wir stehen geblieben sind.
Was zuletzt funktioniert hat.
So, also starten wir mal den Upload.
No route to host, weil andere IP gekriegt.
Was für eine IP habe ich gekriegt.
Nochmal neu Upload.
InsaneAvi, wenn du ziemlich gute, also wenn du Sichtlinie oder sag mal, wenn nicht so viel dazwischen ist, kannst du mit Laura auch 2,7 Kilometer machen.
Bei mir ist das Problem, ich wohne zwar nicht mitten in der Stadt, aber auch nicht so richtig am Rand.
Also wenn du wirklich in der Stadt wohnst, da geht das keine 2,7 Kilometer.
Allerdings geht das manchmal, also mit Glück kann das trotzdem gehen.
Ich habe schon Leute gesehen im Internet, die machen das so.
Die positionieren ihre Laura Antennen quasi Richtung Wolken, Richtung Himmel.
Und die hoffen dann, dass mal irgendein reflektiertes Signal ankommt.
Aber das funktioniert glaube ich nicht zuverlässig.
Aber selbst wenn ich den Funkmaß baue, bringt das nichts, weil der Sensor selbst, der ist ja bloß 10 cm über der Erde.
Minecraft Mod, nee habe ich null.
Fuck, ich habe schon wieder nicht geguckt, was hat es jetzt für eine IP gekriegt.
Ah, 60 146.
So, gucken wir mal, ob das Ganze funktioniert jetzt.
Ah, geh runter.
Ok, also das Upload, was ist das hier?
Ah, was ist das?
Geh runter.
Ok, clear, jetzt schreckt.
Also der Upload funktioniert.
Sieht man ja, es wird immer weniger und dann schreibt das Ganze, nee auf Flash schreibt das noch nicht, fertig, sehr schön.
Also der Upload klappt, also sprich ich kann die Firmware hochschieben, die Firmware kommt dann hier raus.
Und hier muss ich jetzt checken, ob ich die Firmware, wie ich die Firmware auf das Gerät schreibe.
WD MyCloud, keine Ahnung was das ist.
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist, irgendwas mit externer Festplatte wahrscheinlich.
Oh, das ist ein cooles Gehäuse, tatsächlich.
Aber ich weiß nicht, wie gut das mit dem Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor funktioniert, weil der muss ja wahrscheinlich in den Boden.
Also, es gab übrigens gestern noch einen schönen Hinweis, was wir machen sollen ist, wir sollen noch checken, ob die Firmware die passende Checksumme hat, nachdem wir sie erhalten haben.
Da habe ich mal schlau gemacht, wie das Ganze geht.
Man kann hier sagen, Update, Set MD5summe, da kann man dann irgendwas, da kann man irgendeine MD5summe setzen und am Ende, wenn das Update fertig ist, checkt er, ob die MD5summe passt.
So, und deswegen machen wir das jetzt erstmal mit der Checksumme, ich habe mir eben schon angeschaut, wie das Ganze funktioniert.
Also, ich würde sagen, wir machen das total simpel, das ist ja nichts, was jetzt absolut hacker-resistent, was auch immer wahnsinnig secure sein soll.
Ich möchte damit meine Geräte updaten und ich möchte es über HTTPS machen, aus nicht wirklich nachvollziehbaren Gründen, weil es ist eh außer meine Geräte in diesem WLAN niemand.
Das heißt, ich könnte es auch eigentlich ohne Probleme über HTTPS machen, aber irgendwie will ich es lieber über HTTPS machen, was ja auch der Vorteil ist, dass wenn mal irgendein Gastgerät drin hängt oder so, kann keiner meine Passwörter aus der Firmware auslesen.
Was schwachsinnig ist, was eh keiner macht, aber ich finde es einfach besser, Firmware-Updates über HTTPS zu machen, da was ich weiß, da ist wurscht, was ich übertrage, es kann keiner lesen unterwegs.
Musst du dann immer die neue Check-Summe eingeben? Ja, deswegen machen wir das über einen Parameter, und zwar machen wir das so.
What the fuck? Das, wir quarten das Ganze mal.
Und zwar übergeben wir das einfach als Parameter und sagen Check-Summe gleich.
Jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, wo unsere Firmware liegt, MD5-Summe. Unsere Firmware liegt nämlich hier drunter.
Das ist unser Firmware-File. So, dann machen wir das jetzt nämlich so.
So, jetzt haben wir die Firmware hier drin, und die können wir jetzt bei jedem Upload hier automatisch reinschreiben.
Weil man sich nicht vercopy-pastet natürlich. So, und jetzt überträgt er bei jedem, natürlich nicht so, sondern so.
Und jetzt überträgt er bei jedem Update als Parameter in der Uhr die MD5-Check-Summe für die Firmware.
Das können wir jetzt ausprobieren, ob das Ganze funktioniert.
Und zwar, wir machen jetzt hier keine Updates, wir lassen uns jetzt mal die MD5-Summe ausgeben.
Und zwar gibt es da eine, habe ich im Vorfeld schon geguckt, wie das Ganze funktioniert.
Weil es gibt hier so ein Get-Params, und da gibt es ein Get-Query-Parameter.
So, und da wollen wir nämlich Check-Summe haben, also sprich das da, das was wir hier übergeben in der Uhr.
Warum benutze denn die MD5-Summe aber dann HTTPS? Na, das eine hat mit dem anderen nur bedingt was zu tun.
HTTPS ist in dem Fall dafür da, dass der sehr sehr unwahrscheinliche Fall, aber der ist damit halt auch ausgeschlossen,
dass jemand unterwegs quasi mitlesen könnte, was ich zum Controller als neue Firmware uploade.
Und die MD5-Check-Summe ist dafür da, dass ich kontrollieren kann, dass die Firmware fehlerfrei angekommen ist.
Ob jetzt MD5 oder Shard 256 ist doch wurscht.
Für die reine Verifizierung, dass die Firmware richtig übertragen wurde, tut es der MD5-Check-Summe auch.
Und ich glaube eingebaut hier in der Update-Library vom ESP ist auch nur MD5.
Und deswegen mache ich es auch mit MD5, weil warum soll ich was eigenes stricken, wenn hier schon MD5 dabei ist,
was die Überprüfung für mich macht. Das ist dann einfacher.
Also, wir holen uns jetzt mal den Check-Sum-Parameter.
Dann brauchen wir da einen Standard-String.
Den nennen wir irgendwie Check-Sum. Ich vorstelle mal das Ding ein.
Check-Sum. So, jetzt gucken wir nach, wenn der Parameter da ist.
Oh, wie macht man das in C++ überhaupt? Ich glaube, das ist 0.
Dann sagen wir Update Set MD5. Nee, das geht anscheinend nicht.
Also, von der Idee sollte es jetzt folgendermaßen funktionieren.
Ich schicke hier eine Check-Summe mit. Und der guckt, ob ich eine Check-Summe mitgeschickt habe.
Dann überprüft er am Ende des Updates, ob die Check-Summe stimmt.
So, und warum darf ich in C++ nicht überprüfen, ob das leer ist?
Was und Check-Sum? Ah ja, tatsächlich.
Macht er... Nee, oder auch nicht. Warum eigentlich nicht?
Steht doch explizit da, ich soll das als Referenz übergeben.
Warum geht das nicht mit einem Und davor? Hä?
Der sagt doch, ich soll das als Referenz. Meine Patrik hat auch recht.
Also, ich habe es eigentlich falsch gemacht, aber jetzt mache ich es richtig und jetzt ist es kaputt.
C++. Jetzt sind wir wieder beim eigentlichen Thema.
So, kann mir irgendjemand erklären, warum das nicht funktioniert?
Okay. Ist das hier Null überhaupt?
Ist das hier Null oder ist das schon standardmäßig initialisiert?
Nee, na, das... Kann man sowas machen?
Warum kann ich nicht gucken, ob da nichts drin ist?
Kann ein String nicht Null sein oder so? Ist das vielleicht so eine komische Convention in C++?
C++, Check, If, Null, String.
Weil du String empty brauchst. Wo soll ich das wissen? Da! Okay, String empty.
Okay, also wenn String not empty ist... Ich glaube, das ist jetzt ein Bug, die Anzeige.
So, okay, das scheint zu funktionieren.
Das kann nur Null sein, wenn es ein Pointer ist. Ja, dann erklär mir aber mal...
Dann erklär mir aber mal, warum das hier valid ist.
Strings sind intern bestimmt schon Referenzen. 100% sonst wird das hier nicht funktionieren.
Weil in C++ alles valid ist. Aber guck mal, ein String muss ja eine Referenz sein, sonst könnte ich meinen normalen String ja nicht als Referenz übergeben.
Und wenn ich es als Referenz übergebe, ist es ein Fehler.
Das heißt im Endeffekt, ein String ist schon eine Referenz und das ist erlaubt.
Das ergibt sonst keinen Sinn.
Das heißt, es ist schon eine Referenz. Und aus irgendwelchen Gründen ist der Vergleich mit Null nicht erlaubt.
Deswegen lassen wir es einfach so und das muss funktionieren.
Ohne Scheiß, hätten wir dann einen Char Array, dann wüsste man wenigstens, wie es funktioniert.
So, das lassen wir jetzt so und jetzt uploaden wir das mal und gucken uns...
Ah nee, Moment, ich sollte vielleicht mal den Kram ausgeben.
Serial brindeln und zwar die Checksumme.
Die Checksumme geben wir aber nur aus, wenn was gesetzt ist.
Auf uploaden, ich muss nochmal uploaden.
Achso, das geht natürlich nicht, weil es ja ein Standard String ist und das ist ja ein Arduino String.
Einfach voidcasten, im Zweifelsfall ist dann alles möglich.
Upload, fertig.
So, dann schauen wir mal, was jetzt passiert.
Vielleicht sollte ich einfach mal als Binary Data irgendwas einfach mal leer lassen.
Ah nee, da geht es nicht.
Nein, what the fuck.
Zu schnell, zu viel.
Warum eigentlich genau 10++, weil das das Einzige ist, was ich nehmen kann.
Okay Moment, wo ist jemand anderer, der muss mal weg kurz und sehe ich das nicht.
Es muss 10++ sein.
Du hast plus, es gibt zwei Varianten, also es gibt drei Varianten, den ESP32 zu programmieren.
So drei verbreitete.
Es gibt das SDK vom Hersteller, das ist ESP-IDF, das ist reines C, das ist reines C.
Dann gibt es eine Arduino Portierung auf den ESP32 als Aufbau auf dem ESP-IDF.
Das ist C++ und dann gibt es auch die Möglichkeit eine Micropython Firmware zu flashen und Micropython zu machen.
Die Sache ist die, warum ich Arduino nehme, weil die ganzen Geräte und Sensoren Libraries, weil es dort für Arduino am meisten gibt.
Am liebsten würde ich es in ESP-IDF rein in C machen, allerdings hört es da schon auf, beispielsweise meine kleinen LCD Displays anzusprechen.
Das funktioniert damit schon nur noch sehr umständlich.
Das ist halt super, weil es für Arduino die ganzen Libraries gibt.
Es gibt da noch so eine Hybrid-Möglichkeit.
Man kann ESP-IDF verwenden und man kann die Arduino-Implementierung dort als Modul laden.
Das Problem ist jetzt, das ist im Prinzip das, was die Arduino-Leute auch machen, also die Arduino-Portierungsleute auch machen, nur dass die davon quasi stable releases rausbringen.
Die Sache ist plus die, dass das permanent broken ist und man jeden Tag eine halbe Stunde nachpatchen muss, bis es funktioniert wieder.
Ok, mal gucken, ob das jetzt mit der Check-Summe funktioniert, was ich kümmere. Ah, jetzt, guck mal da, Check-Summe.
Check-Summe, wunderbar, funktioniert. Exzellent.
Habt ihr das gesehen, Check-Summe ist am Start.
Gut, dann legen wir mal los.
Also wir wissen jetzt schon mal, dass die Daten, die wir uploaden, parkoural ankommen.
Das heißt, wir sagen jetzt Update Begin. Update Begin möchte eine Größe haben und wohin ich mein Firmware-Update schreiben will.
Was wurde aus dem Ladebalken? Der kommt gleich noch, der Ladebalken. Der Ladebalken kommt gleich noch. Den bauen wir gleich noch ein.
Klappt die Validierung auf die Check-Summe? Das werden wir gleich sehen.
Hast du schon mal versucht, ein Arduino über den Raspberry zu programmieren? Ne, hab ich noch nicht. Hab ich noch nicht. C++, du tust mir echt leid.
Ja, ich hab fast keine andere Möglichkeit in dem Fall.
Also die Firmware-Update-Funktion möchte die Länge haben von der neuen Firmware und das Ziel, wo es hin soll.
Länge kriegen wir aus dem Request und das Ziel ist Flash.
Das Update ist relativ clever. Also die eingebaute Update-Funktion vom ESP32 hier, die ist relativ clever.
Wenn das failt, der hat standardmäßig zwei, zwei Partitionen. Nennen wir das mal Partitionen. Drei, drei Partitionen.
Der hat einmal, ich sag mal Partitionen. Null, das ist ein Boot-Manager. Ganz, ganz mini Boot-Manager.
Partition eins ist eine Firmware. Partition zwei ist eine Firmware für OTA, also sprich für Update.
Das heißt, er schreibt quasi erst mal das Update. Der überschreibt seine eigene Firmware nicht.
Der schreibt die Firmware quasi auf eine zweite Partition und erst wenn ich sage Update, Finish, End, dann switcht er das im Bootloader um.
Und beim nächsten Boot ist er auf der neuen Firmware.
Und als dritte Partition hast du so ein Minifile-System, wo du Dateien drauf speichern kannst.
Du bekommst auch Mitleid. Du bekommst OpenGL+, C++ Mitleid. Das ist ja beides eklig.
Man muss sagen, das ist gar nicht so schlecht. Also sogar auf dem ESP8266 finde ich dieses Feature super.
Man kann nämlich einstellen, man macht 1MB Firmware-Partition, 1MB Update-Partition und 2MB File-System-Partition.
Machen das Konsolen auch mehrere Partitionen für Updates. In etwas komplizierter Art und Weise ziemlich sicher.
Jedes Gerät, was kaputt gehen kann bei einem Firmware-Update, sollte das so machen.
Außer Nintendo. Ich weiß es bei den neuen Nintendo-Konsolen nicht. Bei der Switch war das, äh nicht bei der Switch, bei der Wii.
Bei der Wii hat Nintendo das bei Firmware-Updates ganz, ganz merkwürdig gemacht.
Die Wii hatte alle Firmware-Releases, die es jemals gegeben hat, mit irgendwie dem inkrementellen Algorithmus dahinter, dass sie nicht alle speichern müssen.
Die hatten alle Firmware-Releases, die es gegeben hat, immer auf dem internen Speicher drauf.
Weil Nintendo einen absolut Big-Brain-Schachzug gemacht hat. Die haben sich gedacht, Alter, wir können uns Flash-Speicher sparen.
Und die haben die Firmware gesplittet. Die hatten quasi einen internen Mini-Firmware-Teil und der restliche Teil, für den man für Spiele und Zeug gebraucht hat, war auf der Game-Disc mit drauf.
Das heißt, dass aber der Firmware-Teil, der auf der Game-Disc mit drauf war, zu dem internen Firmware-Teil auf der Wii passen musste.
Deswegen mussten die auf der Wii jegliche jemals erschienene Firmware-Version behalten.
Weil sonst hättest du ein altes Spiel eingelegt und es wäre nicht mehr gestartet.
Das war Nintendo Big-Brain-Logik.
Das ist Mario Galaxy beste.
Okay, ein Remix.
Was benutzt du für eine Programmiersprache, wenn du frei wählen darfst? Kommt auf an für was. Aber wenn ich die auf freie Auswahl hab und was, wofür es sich eignet, eindeutig immer C-Sharp, weil es meine absolute Lieblingssprache ist.
So, also wir machen jetzt ein Update.
Auf das Flash, auf das interne Flash.
Das heißt, wir sagen, Update Begin sollte es nicht passen, hier nicht übereinstimmen.
Dann geben wir den Fehler aus und ich würde sagen, wir returnen oder so.
Vielleicht returnen wir. Mal gucken.
So.
Kennst du gute Ressourcen zu Valken? Nee.
Ich muss sagen, 3D-Programmieren hab ich auch nur sehr grundlegend Ahnung.
Ich hab mal in Rust mit Corona.
Ist nicht Corona, ich hab mich nur verschluckt an so komischen Blaubeeren.
Ich hab mal in Rust eine T-Kanne angezeigt in OpenGL.
Eine T-Kanne ist so diese Standardübung, die jeder macht, der OpenGL verwende.
Aber mehr als eine T-Kanne angezeigt in OpenGL hab ich noch nie.
Dank diesem Tutorial weiß ich aber, was der Unterschied ist zwischen einem Pixel-Shader und einem Vertex-Shader.
Der eine sagt, wo der Pixel ist, der andere sagt, welche Farbe der Pixel hat.
Okay, also wir schreiben das Update auf das Flash-Speichern.
Wenn wir nicht genug Platz haben, dann schmeißen wir eine Fehlermeldung.
Dann lesen wir die Firmware ein.
Das erste, was wir bei jedem Schleifendurchlauf machen, ist gucken, ob es irgendwelche Fehler gibt beim Updaten.
Sollte es Fehler beim Updaten geben, schreiben wir das Ganze als Fehler raus und brechen ab.
Das Brechen ab speichern wir uns jetzt, weil wir gehen natürlich davon aus,
dass wir fehlerfreien, perfekten Code programmieren, der nie abstürzt.
Gerade mit dieser tollen HTTP-Library, da brauchen wir keine Fehlerbehandlung.
Wir geben die Fehlermeldung raus und alles ist gut.
Hier schreiben wir die Firmware jetzt auf das Flash-Speicher.
Kurz überlegen, ging das noch mal hier Update?
So, und da muss man jetzt sagen, glaubt, wie viel er schreiben soll.
Also sprich, Buffer, was wir hier oben von unserem HTTP-Request gekriegt haben,
speichern wir jetzt auf das Flash vom Controller.
Und so viel, wie wir gelesen haben, also sprich, wahrscheinlich meistens 512.
So, dann haben wir das ins Flash geschrieben. Jetzt können wir nämlich gleich gucken, ob es funktioniert.
Da haben wir das ins Flash geschrieben.
Wir haben hier unsere tolle Fehlerbehandlung. Wenn es irgendeinen Fehler gibt, starten wir einfach neu.
Das machen wir hier oben auch, easy. Wenn es einen Fehler gibt, starten wir neu, easy.
Das ist die beste Fehlerbehandlung aller Zeiten.
Die Content-Length machen wir mal weg.
So, wenn das hier durchgelaufen ist, das bedeutet, ich hab das komplette Firmware abgeloadet.
Würde bei einem Neustart nicht jedes Mal trotzdem alles nicht wiederholen?
Nee, das wird ja erst getriggert, wenn ich in Upload starte.
Und dass ich noch in Upload starten kann, muss ich neu starten, weil diese komische HTTPS-Webserver-Library
ein bisschen verbuggt ist und die dann hängt.
So, also wenn die Schleife hier durch ist, dann bedeutet das, der Request ist fertig, ich hab alles hochgeladen.
Wenn ich alles hochgeladen hab, checken wir am Ende noch mal abschließend, ob alles funktioniert hat.
Das habe ich übrigens abgeguckt aus einer anderen Update-Geschichte.
Da kann ich sagen, okay, Update ist fertig, lass mal Update abschließen und nur wenn das hier klappt,
dann startet er auch neu und lädt das neue Update.
So, wenn das nicht funktioniert hat, dann geben wir die Fehlermeldung aus und starten neu.
Und wenn das Ganze, wobei das mit dem Neustarten können wir uns eigentlich sparen, mit dem Neustart machen wir E.
Wir starten immer neu, wenn wir fertig sind, starten wir immer neu.
Es gibt keine andere Variante.
Es wird immer neu gestartet.
Sprich, wenn wir hier angekommen sind, dann sollte eigentlich Update finished.
Dann sollte das Update eigentlich funktioniert haben.
Restarting, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt.
Gucken wir mal, ob der klappt, den ich hier gebastelt hab.
Vielleicht erst Return-Status-Code, ja, das wäre gut.
Dann hängt nämlich der Kleint nicht.
Aber machen wir noch einen Mini-Delay rein, dass er auch Zeit hat, das zurückzuschicken.
Würde es nicht auch Sinn machen, den Fehler als HTTP-Response zurückzuziehen?
Ja, würde es, würde es, würde es, müssen wir gleich machen.
Müssen wir gleich noch richtig machen.
So, also von der Idee her, sollte der jetzt die neue Firmware hochladen,
einen checksum-Check machen, die, nee, am Ende sollte er die checksum checken.
Der sollte die Firmware hochladen, auf Flash-Speicher schreiben,
einen MD5-Check machen am Ende, hier.
Und dann neu starten und neue Firmware laden.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt klappt.
Ah, vielleicht sollte, vielleicht hätte ich mal eine...
Och, das geht doch relativ schnell.
Wenn das jetzt klappt, geht das wirklich sehr, sehr zügig.
Update finished, restarting.
Äh, ich macht, ich, nee, nee, so wie ich das verstehe, ist das, hier setzt man...
Was?
Oh.
Nee, ich glaube, ich habe da Mist gemacht.
Ähm, so wie ich das verstehe, setzt man hier, was am Ende erwartet wird.
Also, ich vermute mal, hier setzt man, was es sein soll,
und in Ende probiert er, ob das, ähm, dann auch stimmt.
Das heißt, ich muss gar nichts selbst machen.
So, das Update hat angeblich funktioniert.
Wir können jetzt mal ausprobieren, ob das Update funktioniert hat.
Wir schreiben hier einfach mal in unsere Loop rein, Loop 1, 2, 3.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt ein Update mache und danach starte,
dann, äh, sollte da jetzt Loop 1, 2, 3 stehen.
Also sprich, wenn jetzt gleich Loop 1, 2, 3 da steht,
hat das Firmware-Update übers WLAN funktioniert.
Vorher muss ich aber noch eine Sache machen.
Ich muss dem Ding ja sagen, dass er die Firmware neu kompilieren soll vor dem Uploaden.
Ähm, Home, wo liegt denn der Kram noch mal?
Home? Max?
Meine Plattform AIO?
Äh, ach du Scheiße.
Wo liegt denn der Kram noch mal?
PIO.
Oh.
Äh.
Oh je. Wo liegt das Plattform AIO-Library noch mal?
Äh, äh, Binary noch mal.
Ähm.
Lip?
Naja.
Irgendwo hier. PNF?
Bin?
Ups.
Ah, da ist es.
Ah.
Jetzt kompiliert er den Kram und lädt es direkt nacheinander hoch.
Genau, kompiliert die Firmware und jetzt lädt er es ab.
Ab. Jetzt lädt er es ab.
What the fuck?
Das heißt, wenn er jetzt alles richtig gemacht hat, neu startet, oh.
Sollte da Monitor eigentlich gleich, Loop 1, 2, 3 stehen.
Bam.
Easy, hat funktioniert. Firmware-Update über WLAN erfolgreich.
Siehste? Und alles nur dank der tatkräftigen Unterstützung des Q-Chats.
Sonst hätte das nicht funktioniert.
Gut, Firmware-Update funktioniert.
So, das, was wir hier gemacht haben, ist natürlich ein bisschen fail.
Weil die Verbindung kackt ab und er startet neu.
Das ist nicht so Sinn und Zweck der Sache.
Das sollten wir doch irgendwie anders...
Wird das auf GitHub veröffentlicht? Kann ich machen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Leute das wirklich interessiert.
Aber ich kann hier machen.
Ich kann das so einfach als...
Ohne, ohne meine, ohne mein WLAN-Passwort vielleicht.
Einfach mal so pushen.
So, vielleicht so als Example.
ESP32, HTTPS, OTA.
So, also.
Das funktioniert schon mal, das ist schön.
Das Passwort...
Ich hab eh ein eigenes Streaming-WLAN, da passiert nichts Großartiges.
Ja, gut, wenn das jetzt funktioniert.
Ist doch schon mal nice.
Dann...
Dann können wir das jetzt noch ein bisschen schöner machen.
Wir brauchen noch ne ordentliche...
Wir brauchen noch ne ordentliche Ausgabe, was es macht.
Weil aktuell sehen wir hier gar nix.
Wir haben ja unsere Curl-Probe.
Wir haben ja unsere Curl-Progress-Bar.
Aber hier haben wir überhaupt keine ordentliche Ausgabe,
äh, was das Ding gerade macht.
So.
Das heißt, hier geben wir dann irgendwie so was aus,
von der Richtung hier Update in Progress und dann Prozent.
Und da machen wir dann auch unseren krassen Spinner hin.
Wo haben wir den Spinner? Hier.
Der Spinner wird jetzt gleich noch eingebaut.
Dass es dann auch...
...stylish ausschaut.
Vielleicht kriegen wir das sogar bei Curl.
Als Antwort können wir das dann schicken.
So.
Also.
Sagen wir mal Update.
Äh, Prozent von...
...ja, 100.
Ähm.
Nicht Printel, Printf.
So.
Da müssen wir jetzt irgendwie den Progress errechnen.
Wie können wir den Progress errechnen,
wo wir gerade sind beim Update?
Ähm.
Skillkiller schreibt,
ich möchte prüfen, ob in einem Bild ein weißes Icon vorhanden ist.
Das Icon ist aber halb durchsichtig.
Hast du eine Idee, wie ich sowas trotzdem über die RGB-Zahlen finden kann?
Ja.
Indem du es nicht mit RGB machst, sondern mit RGBA.
Indem du noch den Transparenz-Channel mitnimmst.
Weil du musst ja einen Transparenz-Channel haben.
Sonst wäre das nicht halb durchsichtig.
Oder verstehe ich das nicht.
Also dadurch, dass das Bild durchsichtig ist,
musst du ja einen Transparenz-Channel haben,
sonst wäre das Bild nicht durchsichtig.
Da musst du einfach in den Transparenz-Channel gucken,
ob an der Stelle, wo du Pixel suchst, ob da was transparent ist.
Kommt drauf an, wenn er nur einen Screenshot hat,
dann hat er den Alpha-Channel nicht mehr.
Ja, aber wenn er nur einen Screenshot hat,
dann ist auch nichts durchsichtig.
Ach, du hast einen Screenshot.
Ah, okay.
Sprich, das war mal durchsichtig.
Du hast es gescreenshotted.
Und jetzt ist es nicht mehr durchsichtig.
Jetzt hast du immer den gleichen Hintergrund.
Der Hintergrund vom Screenshot.
Wie könnte man sowas gut erkennen?
Da fällt mir jetzt nichts ein.
Also wenn du... Hast du das Icon
in der ursprünglichen Variante?
Da könntest du wahrscheinlich irgendwas subtrahieren
voneinander und gucken, ob es dann schwarz ist oder so.
Aber da fällt mir jetzt nichts Gescheites ein.
Da muss man irgendeine... irgendeine...
Magic machen wahrscheinlich, dass man das rauskriegt.
Moin, BananaWave.
Jetzt habt ihr mich ganz verwirrt.
Was wollte ich denn machen?
Das ist, glaube...
Es könnte sogar V-Sports sein.
Ja.
Das scheint V-Sports zu sein.
Was soll ich denn machen?
Nee, da habe ich gerade spontan keine Idee.
Das ist auch kompliziert.
Generell, Bilderkennung ist nicht ohne.
Aber wir sind hier im Jahr 2020.
Lasst es einfach von der Microsoft
und Bilder-Kategorisierungs-AI in Azure berechnen.
Und bezahle einfach pro Request.
Easy.
So, was wollte ich jetzt machen?
Ich habe das voll verdrängt, Leute.
Ah, hier. Anzeige, Update, Progress.
Ähm, okay.
Wie kann ich den Progress berechnen?
Aber sagen wir mal hier.
Auto, Update, Progress.
Der fängt ja mal mit Null an.
Sollte zumindest.
Hier oben haben wir Null Progress,
weil wir haben auch nichts eingelesen.
Ähm, so, da haben wir File Length.
File Length, so, und irgendwie
müsste man doch jetzt ausrechnen können.
Also quasi sowas in Form von...
Wenn das was eingelesen ist,
dann sagen wir jetzt einfach
Update, Progress.
Nee, nicht plus gleich, gleich.
Ähm, was haben wir hier oben? File Length.
File Length.
Ähm, File Length ist das,
was ich aktuell eingelesen habe.
Also im Prinzip...
Länge?
Länge durch File Length, oder?
Gibt das Sinn?
Also quasi insgesamt Länge.
Vielleicht soll ich das jetzt mal besser wählen.
Insgesamt Länge durch File Länge.
Ist das die Prozent? Dann mal 100?
Ergibt, ergibt das Sinn?
Passt das, was ich da mach?
Ist das Visual Studio Code? Ja.
Gibt das Sinn, was ich hier mache?
Probieren wir mal aus, ob das funktioniert,
ob wir jetzt eine ordentliche Anzeige bekommen,
wie weit das Update ist.
Du, du, du, du, du, du, du.
So.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert
mit dem Progress.
Wie ich mir das gedacht hab.
Oh.
Quickmaps.
Nicht so ganz.
Ach nee, ist ja auch falsch rum.
Ist aber auch falsch rum, oder?
Das stoppt jetzt bei 100 von 100 gleich.
Das ist ja auch falsch rum.
Ich bin ja auch.
Okay, warte mal.
Ich will ja eigentlich auch
File Length
mal 100
durch
insgesamt Länge.
So, ich glaube,
das ist eher das, was ich haben will.
Quickmaps,
Leute.
Excellent.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt klappt.
Alles andere easy, aber so Ausgaben
macht es immer kompliziert.
So.
Upload.
Bam.
Okay.
Funktioniert's?
Ah, yes, excellent.
Ich habe wieder
mein Headset ausgemacht auf der einen Seite.
Wie geht denn das?
Wie schaffe ich das immer,
mein Headset auf der einen Seite auszumachen?
Das kann auch nicht sein.
Moment, ich glaube,
das ist einfach ein bisschen.
So.
Das hat rumgespackt, das Kabel.
Ah, ja.
Wieso nicht Prozent dahinter?
Hat keine Tieferin, so ein Blobsrusher.
Drei Monate, danke schön.
Komm mal, funktioniert.
Update 100, 100, 100.
Huge.
Wir können das jetzt noch besser machen.
Wir können jetzt sagen, Progress.
Und jetzt machen wir so,
nur wenn der aktuelle Progress
besser ist wie der letzte Progress,
nur dann updaten wir
Progress.
Und nur dann
geben wir was aus, dann spammen wir nicht so rum
und spammen immer nur dann rum, wenn wir neue
Prozentzahl erreicht haben.
Was passiert hier?
Wir updaten über das WLAN
meinen
einen ESP32.
Allerdings nicht einfach
nur updaten über das WLAN, sondern
über HTTPS updaten. Also
über Schlüssel updaten.
Über verschlüsselte Verbindung updaten.
Und es scheint tatsächlich zu
funktionieren.
Ja, kann man.
OK, MIM, kann man.
So, gucken wir mal
wieder, ob das Firmware-Update klappt.
Bam.
So, und von der Idee
jetzt,
solltet ihr jetzt weniger spammen und trotzdem
den Progress anzeigen.
Hey!
Easy.
Funktioniert.
Es geht sogar relativ schnell, oder?
So, dass das ein verschlüsseltes Update ist.
Also über eine verschlüsselte Verbindung geht.
Restart, finished. Jetzt startet er neu mit Loop 5.
Yep.
Funktioniert. Cool.
Sebaru, du hättest es gerne auf 10 Nachkommastellen
genau, ja, das können wir machen.
Wir sorgen
einfach dafür, dass wir hier, wir verwenden
Doubles. Wir machen
Floats, Floats sind uns zu ungenau, oder?
Wir verwenden Doubles.
Wenn schon richtig.
Nee, wir lassen das so, das ist doch ganz nice.
Ja, das
funktioniert erstaunlich
gut.
So, jetzt können wir nochmal ein,
wir wollen ja unseren Spinner noch einbauen.
Hier, den da.
Spinner.
So.
Was hat er eigentlich
für Schmerzen hier? Warum kackt, also
weil der Header fehlt hier. Include
Arduino.
Hat jemand von euch eigentlich eine Ahnung?
Das frage ich mich schon, frage ich mich
schon eine ganze Weile. Ich meine, ich könnte Google
fragen, aber der Chat
ist ja immerhin, immerhin
der, der Chat
weiß das bestimmt auch.
Was ist denn der Unterschied
zwischen Anführungszeichen
Arduino oder
Spitze Klammer auf und zu
Arduino.
Jetzt noch was, weil wo die Versionsnummer
ausgelesen wird.
Du meinst quasi,
if Versionsnummer größer, nur dann updaten.
Klammer auf Klammer zu sucht im Pfad,
der mit I angegeben ist. Ja gut, da editiere
ich eh von Hand nichts dran.
Keks, Kekspoint Wastes.
Kekspoint Wastes
im Chat.
Kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor, was ist das?
Ah ne, kenn ich nicht, aber Kirby
Musik, immer, immer gut.
So, unser toller, toller
Spinner. Den können wir
jetzt mal wieder einbauen.
Und zwar
löschen wir mal alles, was auf der
Zeile steht.
Wir brauchen einen,
wo haben wir ihn hier? Wir brauchen ein
globales Spinner-Objekt.
Geht nicht, weil
Include
Helper.
Macht man eigentlich Include Helper?
Dings?
HPP?
Ach, was soll ich immer machen?
Kann man eigentlich auch direkt CPP-Dateien
inkluden?
Und dann einfach alles, alles in einem
schreiben und auf diesen altertümlichen
Header und Implementierungskram
scheißen?
Äh, wieso eigentlich
eine Checksumme mit MD5 und ich mit
2.256? Ganz einfach.
Weil das Ding nur MD5-Summe
eingebaut unterstützt und alles andere
müsst ihr selbst machen.
Ich verstehe eh nicht, warum die mal
sich im C++-Cremium
nicht mal eh ein bisschen
den Sachen widmen, dass das
ein bisschen moderner wird, alles.
Das Ganze rumhantieren
mit irgendwelchen Header-Files
und, und
man muss es so
inkluden. Es fängt ja schon damit an,
dass man in Header
sowas hier oben reinschreiben muss.
Ups, hallo.
Dass es nicht doppelt included
und solche Dinger. Warum muss ich mich um so einen
Crap überhaupt noch kümmern im Jahr 2020?
Die sollen ein ordentliches Modulsystem
machen.
machen und auf
diesen ganzen Header-Implementierungskram
scheißen, meiner Ansicht nach.
Dann könnte man
nämlich auch einen ordentlichen Paketmanager
für C++ machen.
So wie es jede
halbwegs moderne Programmiersprache
mittlerweile hat.
Das ist richtig oi, 3-Head.
Aber das C++-Cremium
spritzt sich eh immer die harten Sachen
bevor die irgendwas beschließen.
Anders kann ich mir da viele Sachen nicht erklären.
Ich mein, die C++-
Lambda-Syntax ist schon
abenteuerlich.
Aber wenn man da noch checken muss, dass man
an manchen Stellen Funktionen verwenden kann,
aber keine Lambdas verwenden kann und manchmal
auch keine Funktionen in Klassen, aber Funktionen
außerhalb von Klassen funktionieren,
manche Sachen du als Standard-Function
casten kannst und manche nicht
und dann ist
vorbei.
Und eine Sache, über die ich ja immer
flamen könnte bei C++ ist,
warum enthält Standard-String kein
to-lower und to-upper?
Sind das so
bloated-Methoden,
dass eine Standard-Library-String-
Implementierung
kein to-upper und to-lower kann?
Oder wie? Ist das zu bloated für C++?
Es geht nicht.
Es gibt
Standard-to-lower, Standard-to-upper.
Warum
ist sowas nicht eingebaut? Wozu hat man Klassen, wenn
es nicht in der Klasse eingebaut ist?
Es gibt eine Standard-to-lower,
eine Standard-to-upper, aber warum ist das nicht in der
String-Klasse drin?
Damit stelle ich doch in Frage, warum ich überhaupt
Klassen habe, wenn das nicht dabei ist.
Wo habe ich jetzt aufgehört zu editieren?
Helper haben wir eingebunden.
Spinner haben wir auch eingebunden.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, dass wir hier einen schönen
Progress-Balken
hinbekommen.
Spinner.
So.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt klappt.
Wow, es ist kaputt, Leute.
Ach so.
Weil das ja ein
Standard-String ist
und kein
C-String.
Wat?
Was?
Redefination?
Wat?
Ah! Ups!
Ups!
Was hat der hier für Schmerzen?
Wat?
Okay, irgendwas habe ich falsch gemacht.
Warte mal. Irgendwas habe ich falsch gemacht.
Oh!
Falsche rum, Leute. Falsche rum.
Ah, yes.
So ist es besser. Gleich nochmal uploaden.
Falsche rum. Zuerst
der Warte-Balken
und dann die Fortschrittszahlen.
Diesmal hast du sogar die IDE auf, wenn du es gestern
verpasst. Wir haben es gestern fast schon
fertig gemacht.
Ist das Linux? Ja.
Das ist ein
Manjaro mit i3-WM.
Unfair, der Compiler hat immer recht, ja.
So sieht es aus.
Und wenn er mal
nicht recht hat, kannst du auch nichts dagegen machen.
Wann du da
über Corona gesprochen hast, kann ich verstehen, da werde ich auch
abgehauen.
Oh,
Serial Output.
Oh, Leute!
Der Spinner
funktioniert.
Poggers, oder?
Huge Pog.
Moment mal.
Warum schreibt er das jetzt untereinander?
Ach so, weil ich ihm
sage, dass er es untereinander schreiben soll.
Richtig pepega.
Richtig, richtig
pepega.
Ja, Tommy, das kann ich verstehen.
Das ist überall gerade.
Was macht das
BackslashR?
Das setzt
die Stelle, wo geschrieben wird, wieder an Anfang der
Zeit zurück.
Das kommt noch aus
Schreibmaschinenzeiten.
Also sprich,
der schreibt was hin
und beim nächsten Durchlauf
setzt er einfach dort, wo er anfängt zu schreiben,
wieder an Anfang der Zeit und überschreibt das damit.
Warum direkt
viermal? Weil ich mir nicht ganz sicher bin,
eigentlich ist Bescheid, warum viermal
ist, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Eigentlich kompletter Schwachsinn, warum ich viermal reingemacht
hab. Das ist ja kein Tab, der eine gewisse
Länge hat. Ergibt keinen
Sinn, warum es viermal drin ist.
Jetzt wo ich drüber nachdenke,
ergibt das keinen Sinn.
Guckt euch das mal an. Ist das nicht ein
wunderschöner Update-Indikator?
Massive.
Das ist
der Premium-Update-Indikator.
Wahnsinn.
Was macht ein Programm?
Also was ist das Ziel?
Das Ziel ist, dass ich
meine Microcontroller, die ich hier
im Haus im Einsatz hab,
über Wenan updaten kann.
Und nicht einfach nur über
HTTP, sondern ich hab mir in den Kopf gesetzt, ich will das Ganze
über HTTPS machen. Und das
hat sich deutlich schwieriger gestaltet,
als ich das angenommen hab am Anfang.
Über HTTP ist es total einfach.
Da gibt's sogar fertige Sachen.
Da machst du eine neue Firmware,
upload über HTTP und gut ist.
Über HTTPS musst du den Kram selber machen.
Es gibt einen HTTPS
Web-Server hier für
den Controller.
Aber das eigentliche Handling
vom Update muss man selber machen.
Und scheint zu funktionieren.
Und statt Loop 5,
die Loop 5 ist das eigentliche Programm.
Das eigentliche Programm macht aktuell nichts
außer Loop 5 ausgeben.
Also hier, hier kommt das
eigentliche Programm hin.
Den Kram können wir übrigens
rausschmeißen, das hat da überhaupt nichts
zu suchen.
Das eigentliche Programm ist
zur Zeit nur eine Zeile lang.
Es geht mir auch darum, dass ich das Update
implementiert kriege.
Baust du noch einen Trigger zum Start
des Web-Servers ein oder verbrennt die Loop 5
später 24 Stunden Strom und Leistung?
Ja.
Du kannst eh nichts dagegen machen.
Es gibt keine Möglichkeit,
den Kram irgendwie...
Also du kannst in
einem Task
kannst du sagen, ja, ich gebe meine
CPU-Zeit ab.
Aber im Endeffekt,
wenn alle Tasks ihre CPU-Zeit
abgeben,
läuft trotzdem eine Endlosschleife.
Also es gibt da keine
Stromsparmodi für die CPU.
Das Einzige, was du machen kannst, ist
Deep Sleep. Und dann läuft gar nichts mehr
in der Zeit, wo er Deep Sleept.
Das kann man machen. Man kann sagen, Enter
Deep, hier.
Du kannst sagen, du kannst
ESP Deep Sleep Start machen.
Und dann
macht er halt gar nichts mehr.
Bis der Wake Up Interrupt
kommt.
Oder der Wake Up Timer.
Ja, sage ich ja.
Du kannst entweder in den Wake Up Interrupt
oder Wake Up Timer kannst du machen.
Wie versorgst du die Teile
später mit Strom?
Nein, Michael, 50 Billionen.
Es gibt
zwei Varianten, wie ich das
aktuell mache.
Die eine
Sache ist
am Hoftor, der ist
mit Batterie.
So, ich
starte mal kurz ein Update, dann werde ich das alles
beantworten, was im Chat steht.
Erst mal Update,
gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert. Also eine Sache
ist mit Batterie. Da habe ich so eine
500, 1200
mAh
Lithium, was ist das?
Lithium
Polymer?
So eine Standard Akku, so ein Standard
so ein kleiner Akku-Pack ist das.
So eine kleine, kleine
ähm
so ein kleiner Akku, da ist so
so groß
wie Zeigefinger und
Mittelfinger zusammen.
So ein kleiner, kleiner Akku.
Nein, kein 18650, da habe ich
auch welche für. Ah, fuck,
jetzt habe ich geguckt, hat es jetzt funktioniert?
Hat es jetzt eigentlich funktioniert?
Ok, ich muss nochmal updateen.
Ähm
Die verwende ich
bei der Geschichte am Hoftor.
Und
das andere ist halt einfach über USB.
Doch es gibt noch eine dritte Variante,
die Weihnachtsbaumbeleuchtung.
Als einziger, die Weihnachtsbaumbeleuchtung
läuft direkt über das Netzteil,
weil das sind
5V LEDs
für Weihnachtsbaum und
an dem 5V habe ich auch gleich den Controller
dran.
Aber den Rest, den versorge ich tatsächlich
über USB.
Oder halt über einen Akku.
Und mit Deep Sleep
hält das Zeug
auch relativ lang.
Ich habe wieder nicht geguckt.
Leute, hat es jetzt funktioniert? Ich muss jetzt mal was anderes
reinschreiben. Hat es jetzt funktioniert?
Vielleicht soll ich mal kurz gucken,
ob das auch macht, was ich
so denke.
Update, ok.
Ähm
Seit wann bekommt man hier
Kekse und keine Punkte? Seit
diesem Stream.
Ähm
Und Potato, Churchman,
aber der dürfte nicht wirklich viel Strom verbrauchen.
Doch, schon.
Jetzt muss ich mal kurz gucken,
was...
Ah, es hat funktioniert.
Hat funktioniert.
Japp, nice.
Ja, du hast recht.
Nach dem Update
Finished muss ich noch
eine Newline davor machen.
Darf man das überhaupt
in Brindlen reinschreiben?
Geht das?
Macht er das wahrscheinlich?
Macht er das?
Ähm, der verbraucht
nicht viel Strom, doch.
Der verbraucht zwar im Vergleich
zu PC oder im Vergleich
auch zu einem großen Raspberry
oder auch zu einem Raspberry Zero,
braucht er nicht viel Strom,
aber er braucht
zu viel
für an einem Akku.
Und es gibt hier
einen schönen Rechner,
wenn man mal so grob ausrechnen will,
wie lang das hält.
Muss ich mal kurz, ich kann mir immer nicht merken,
wie das Ding heißt. Der da.
Der da.
Da kann man eintragen,
wie viel Zeit das Ganze
im Deep Sleep ist, wieviel die
Hardware braucht, wenn sie an ist, und wieviel das Ganze
im Deep Sleep verbraucht.
Können wir jetzt mal beispielsweise exemplarisch eingeben.
Also die Hardware verbraucht,
sagen wir mal 100,
150 Milliamper,
wenn sehr WLAN.
Ja, du hast recht.
Aber das will ich eh rausschmeißen.
Wenn ich weiß, dass es funktioniert.
Die Build Time.
Echt? Kann ich da einfach...
Geht das?
Habe ich noch nie gemacht. Das ist so
eine globale Makro-Geschichte.
Gibt es hier so ein Time?
Oh.
Exzellent.
Was ist das für ein Ding?
Ein String.
Das probieren wir mal aus. Das muss ich jetzt mal gucken.
Der Chat, der Chat hat mal wieder zugeschlagen.
So. Also.
Gucken wir mal in den Calculator.
Also, die Controller brauchen so
ungefähr 150 Milliamper,
wenn sie WLAN übertragen.
Gehen wir mal von aus,
der braucht nur 100,
weil der ab und zu mal nur
WLAN was überträgt.
Duration of Code Execution lassen wir
aus, weil der läuft permanent.
Sleep Time Null.
So.
Deep Sleep Mode gibt es nicht.
Und das ist eine 1200 mAh
Batterie.
Ging das nicht so?
Musste man da jetzt
irgendwas eintragen?
Ah. Null. Genau.
Also, hier ist im Prinzip egal, wieviel ich
eintrage, ich muss die Sleep Time auf Null stellen.
Das ist das. Also, wenn er permanent
an ist,
dann siehst du, das Ding würde nur
9 Stunden laufen an so einer Batterie.
Also, die verbrauchen nicht viel
Strom. Die verbrauchen im Vergleich zu
einem Raspberry Zero,
verbrauchen die relativ wenig Strom,
aber es reicht trotzdem nicht, um die
24-7 an der Batterie laufen zu lassen.
Eine Möglichkeit wäre
schon, wenn man mit einem bisschen größeren
Akku-Pack dran macht,
einen größeren Akku-Pack dran macht,
und dann irgendwie noch Solar
oder so.
Das wäre
vielleicht möglich, aber die viel
schönere Variante ist,
der Gramm, der muss ja meistens gar nicht permanent
laufen. Also, bei meinem
Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor mache ich so,
da wache ich, glaube ich,
fünfmal am Tag auf und
übertrag was und gehe gleich wieder in
Deep Sleep.
xFaitler1337,
10 Monate, Dankeschön,
huge sub, massive
6-Head-Subscriber.
Der IQ ist heute ja wieder eh ganz
oben im Chat. Das funktioniert,
mit der Build-Times habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Gibt es irgendwo noch woanders, wo
man gucken kann, was es noch so für Makros
gibt? Warum kann ich das Makro überhaupt nicht anklicken?
Wo ist das überhaupt
defined?
Oder ist das irgendeine
Compiler-interne Geschichte, die
irgendwo defined ist?
Gut, die kann ja irgendwo defined sein, weil
sonst
wäre sie ja nicht
dynamisch beim Kompilieren.
Aber das ist cool.
Das gefällt mir echt.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt neu kompiliere
und uploade, dann habe ich danach
gleich die neue Build-Time. Das finde ich
äußerst nice.
Nicht zu sagen.
So, und
zum Thema
Laufzeit.
Man kann mit Deep Sleep echt viel machen.
Weil
ist aber niemand möchte
eigentlich eine Sensor-Daten wirklich
im
Takt von irgendwie
100 Millisekunden übertragen.
Wie viele Zeilen code wohl der normale
GCC-Compiler hat?
Ich glaube,
es gibt bestimmt einen GitHub-Mirror.
Genau.
So. Ach, du Scheiße.
So,
Statistics.
Äh, Statistics.
Wo steht denn der Kram?
Hier.
Ach, ne, da steht gar nicht
wie viel, oder was?
Oh.
Das ist ja doof.
Ich dachte, man sieht, wie viele Code-Zahlen
das sind. Aber ich meine,
es sind ja allein schon
48.000 Dateien.
Also,
GCC ist relativ umfangreich.
Es soll ja mittlerweile so
schlimm sein, dass sogar die GCC-Pros
nicht mehr richtig GCC
gemaintaint kriegen.
Hast du deine Beleuchtung
auch in Home Assistant? Und wie hast du diese
umgesetzt? Nur teilweise, ich hab
gar nicht so viel fancy RGB-Beleuchtung.
Ich hab ein paar
Shelley, Cloud,
Relays.
Die sind am
Lichtschalter.
Die kann man hier in die Dose einbauen.
Äh, am Lichtschalter
sind die.
Dann hab ich eine Lampe
mit wechselnden Farben.
Die zeigt mir an, wie viel
Verspätung die Bahn hat.
Kein Witz.
Das Einzige ist weg von dem Ding.
Ich morgen seh, wie viel Verspätung man
zuhört.
Ähm.
Ansonsten hab ich nicht so viel
Beleuchtung.
Also Dauer blinkt.
Nee, die blinkt nicht. Die schwankt von
grün zu rot. Also von grün
zu orange zu rot.
Also ganz stimmt
die Bildzeit nicht, oder?
20 Uhr 6.
Äh, die
USB-Schalter sind verschickt,
hat AliExpress vor zwei Tagen geschrieben.
Äh, kannst du das erklären,
wie du das mit dem Zug machst, mit der Zugverspätung?
Ja, kann ich dir zeigen.
Musste aber so sagen, so 100%
verlassen kann man sich nicht drauf,
weil die Bahn-AP manchmal rumspackt.
Damit mach ich das.
Also trotzdem immer nochmal auf dem Smartphone gucken,
was wirklich der Fall ist.
Da drüber mach ich das.
Das ist schon fertig eingebaut in Home Assistant.
Da kannst du
äh, Drix in deine Jaml, in deine
Jaml-Konfig ein.
Und musst du sagen, von wo nach wo.
Man kann auch sagen, dass man nur
genau, das ist wichtig, dass man nur direkte
Verbindung.
Nee, ich bin mittlerweile
auch auf dem Standpunkt, dass ich,
wenn ich mit dem zufrieden bin, oder
sag mal so, wenn ich 90% mit dem zufrieden bin,
was es gibt, dass ich eher
das verwende, was es gibt, weil da muss ich mich
nicht drum kümmern.
So, und dann sagst du Only Direct Connections.
Und dann hast du
einen Sensor.
Und dann ist halt Home Assistant Magic, wie du
eine Lampe ansteuerst.
Ja, ich wollte noch was zum Thema
Deep, das wirklich updaten.
Tut sich das nicht, oder, die Zeit?
Da steht die ganze Zeit schon 20.06.
Ach, wahrscheinlich, weil ich nichts geändert
habe. Der hat wahrscheinlich gar nicht
neu kompiliert. Der ist wahrscheinlich
Big Brain und hat gesagt, aha,
es hat sich im Source-Code nichts geändert, ich kompiliere gar nicht
neu.
Und
welchen Output hat sie? Die Lampe leuchtet
wenn der Zug Verspätung hat?
Ne, die Lampe leuchtet morgens
immer, die leuchtet grün,
oder die leuchtet in irgendeinem anderen Farbton
bis zu rot.
Über Orange.
Aha,
jetzt hat's funktioniert.
Okay, man muss, man muss,
der muss aber was kompilieren, dass es klappt.
Abhängig dann
vom Grad der Verspätung, genau.
So sieht's aus.
Exzellent
sieht's aus. Also,
der Update ist updategeschiss funktioniert.
Das ist doch schon mal schön.
Grün für Ausschrauben,
rot für hast dich aufstehen. Na ja, eigentlich eher umgedreht.
Umso mehr Verspätung
und umso länger kann ich theoretisch pennen.
Aber ich sehe das
erst mal nicht auf, wenn ich aufstehe.
Also die hängt im Flur, die hängt über
über meinem Arbeitszimmer,
über meiner Arbeitszimmertür hängt die.
Schräg gegenüber ist die Tür
vor meinem Schlafzimmer, also sprich,
sobald ich morgens rauskomme, sehe ich
was die für eine Farbe hat.
Und wenn die rot ist, dann weiß ich
schon, die Bahn hat's komplett verkackt.
Weil ich bin nicht, ich wohne nicht
so weit weg von der
Station, wo der Zug, also in Aschaffenburg
fährt das los, der Zug.
Und ich bin nicht so extrem weit weg. Das heißt,
wenn das rot ist, wenn ich
aufstehe, dann ist komplett
verschissen. Dann ist sogar die Frage, ob ich
nicht zum nächsten Bahnhof gehe.
Was ist das für eine Lampe?
Boah.
Ähm.
Da muss ich mir meine Amazon-Historie nachgucken.
Irgend so ein billig
billig-China-Ding.
Weil, kann ich dir grad
nicht sagen, gibt's die
Yeelight oder sowas?
Gibt's sowas?
Yeelight?
Das könnte...
Es ist auf jeden Fall über
New Wave steuerbar.
Nee.
Ich sag's dir.
Ich kann's dir sagen, aber das ist nichts Dolles.
Das ist irgendeine billige
China-RGB.
Lampe.
Ich find's nicht.
Vielleicht
hab ich's nicht über Amazon bestellt.
Wenn ich's nicht über Amazon bestellt hab, dann
keine Chance,
jetzt das zu finden.
Ah.
Hose? Nee, ne Hose ist es nicht.
Nee.
Keine Ahnung.
Sollen wir LED
vielleicht suchen?
Hm.
Ah!
Hier, ich hab's gefunden.
Ich habe es gefunden.
Das Ding ist das.
Hab ich mal bei Amazon
billig gesehen,
hab's mir bestellt.
Das Teil.
Geht über...
Nee.
Ist das überhaupt
das Richtige?
Also, ich sag mal so.
Es ist die einzige Lampe, die ich
über meine Amazon-Bestellhistorie gefunden hab.
Die Chance,
dass es diese Lampe ist,
ist relativ hoch.
Es ist auf jeden Fall eine Z-Wave-Lampe.
Weil ich
das meiste Wireless-Zeug an
Geräten über Z-Wave
mache.
Ja.
So. Aber jetzt auch mal kurz ganz kurz
zu sagen zur Laufzeit von dem Ding.
Also, dass man nämlich sieht, dass
Deep Sleep richtig was bringt. Aber
dass man auch das richtige Board haben muss.
Also sprich, wenn sich jemand jetzt so
mit das
beliebteste
ESP32-Boards dürften diese Dinger hier
sein. Die sind auch super
um Sachen auszuprobieren.
Das sind die besten Boards, um irgendwas auszuprobieren.
Die kommen nämlich komplett fertig
mit ordentlich
Flash-Speicher, vorgelöteten
Pins, USB,
alles dabei. Und jetzt nicht so teuer.
Ich kann es über AliExpress kaufen, kostet die Hälfte.
Allerdings sind diese
Boards nicht für Deep Sleep
geeignet. Man kann zwar Deep Sleep
machen oder verbrauchen die auch weniger, aber
die schalten beispielsweise die
Spannungsversorgung und Spannungswanderer für USB
nicht aus.
Was heißt das Verbrauch im Deep Sleep
gar nicht so viel weniger, wie im laufenden
Betrieb?
Zwar schon ein bisschen, aber nicht viel.
So, und das sackt
natürlich massiv.
So, und
wenn man aber das richtige Board dafür
hat, dann braucht das ungefähr
ungefähr,
sagen wir mal, 11 mA
im Deep Sleep.
Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt mal davon
ausgehen, dass wir 2 Sekunden
2 Sekunden was
ausführen und danach 2
Minuten Deep Sleepen,
da sieht man schon, jetzt
hält
jetzt hält die
120 mA Akku
auf einmal schon 24 Tage.
So, und umso sparsamer
man hier wird, umso mehr
geht das ganze hoch.
Das sind mA, das sind mA.
Und das sind mA Stunden.
Oder was meinste?
Also das ist Absicht.
Wenn man, ich sag ja, wenn man
ein Board hat, wenn man
ein Board hat, was
ordentlich Deep Sleep kann,
dann ist das ungefähr der Verbrauch
im Deep Sleep.
Die Node MCUs brauche
eher das, als das.
Brian sagt, habe meine
Hausautomatisierung mit Open Hub
gemacht für KNX.
Nee, 11, dann habe ich mich verfreut, es sind 11
mA im Deep Sleep
mit einem guten Board dafür.
Also ich habe mit Open Hub
noch nichts gemacht, aber Open Hub ist
Java soweit ich weiß,
das hat mich schon mal abgeschreckt damals.
Und mit KNX
habe ich noch gar nichts gemacht.
So, und das Ding, was ich beispielsweise
am Friedhof installiert
hatte, bzw.
wieder installieren werde,
das braucht ungefähr nur
1 Sekunde, oder lassen wir es mal auf 2 Sekunden
beim Ausführen, aber das
Deep Sleep einfach mal 5 Stunden.
Also sagen wir 4
Stunden zu Minuten.
Das kann man Google mittlerweile ganz gut, muss man
nächstes Mal großartig rechnen.
Achso, nee, zu Sekunden, was haben wir?
1 Sekunden. Das Sleep einfach mal
so lang.
Und zack, das ist jetzt mit
Vorsicht zu genießen.
Und es
braucht auch eher 150
mA.
So.
Und sagen wir mal, selbst wenn es 4 Sekunden
braucht, hält das Ding immer noch
1 bis 2 Jahre.
Oder gehen wir mal
hoch.
Sagen wir mal 10.
Und dann hält,
dann hast du jetzt mal, ohne dass du dir
jetzt großartig Mühe gibst,
wenn das Ding halt einfach 4 Stunden
Deep Sleep, 10 Sekunden was macht,
4 Stunden Deep Sleep, und 4 Stunden
Deep Sleep ist okay. Ich brauche nicht
auf die Minute genaue
Bodenfeuchtigkeitswerte.
Das reicht, wenn es ein paar Mal am Tag
macht. Man kann es weiter optimieren,
dass man beispielsweise sagt,
okay, nachts,
wenn es Nacht ist, verschicke ich
nichts.
Kann man ja auch machen, dann braucht man,
spart man nochmal deutlich mehr.
Und da sieht man
schon, wenn man jetzt noch ein bisschen optimiert,
schafft man schon 2 Jahre,
1, 2 Jahre mit
so einem Standardakku.
Schickst du auch den Batteriezustand
mit? Ne.
Da müsste ich nämlich extra
was basteln.
Das Board hat keinen
Sensor für
die Inputspannung von der Batterie.
Da müsste ich da noch irgendwas dran
basteln, dass das geht.
Könnt ihr auf die
Seite, nein, wir machen hier keine
Werbung für irgendwelche komischen Dinger.
So.
Gut, also Update funktioniert.
Jetzt ist die große Preisfrage, Leute.
Es ist 20.23 Uhr, ich habe noch genug
Zeit.
Wir haben jetzt die
Möglichkeit, also folgende Sachen können wir machen.
Ähm.
Wir können
weiter an einer
ESP-Geschichte bauen, denn
ich hatte ja eigentlich noch vor, dass
ich nicht nur Updates machen kann,
sondern auch Log-Dateien über Websockets
empfangen kann.
Also sprich hier Logs, so nach dem Motto.
Das heißt, wir müssen gucken, wie man Websockets
mit der Library macht.
Das ist die eine Variante, was wir machen können
noch, weil die Updates
sehen wir jetzt wohl ganz gut.
Die zweite Variante ist, was wir
machen können, ich schreibe es mal auf.
Erstens, was wir machen können, ist
Secure SSL
Websockets
ausprobieren mit der Library.
Zweitens ist
den Bug suchen
mit der Endlosschleife
in der
Web Server
Library.
Patrick,
hast du irgendwas rausgefunden?
Du wolltest doch mal gucken.
Wir können versuchen, ob wir den
Endlosschleifen bug finden.
Und ihn irgendwie
aushebeln können.
Wenn du das
machen willst mit KNX, ne, ne will ich
nicht, will ich nicht. Garantiert nicht.
Ich will in meinen Wänden nichts mehr
rumbassen. So, die dritte Variante ist,
was ganz was anderes.
Wir können uns mal wieder Stellenanzeigen angucken.
Haben wir bestimmt schon zwei Monate nicht gemacht.
Und ich würde vorschlagen,
als erstes gucken wir uns jetzt noch ein paar
Essensvideos an, weil ich habe
echt riesen Kohldampf und ich habe Essen
neben mir stehen.
Und dann könnt ihr euch ja überlegen, was wir machen wollen.
Drei.
Könnt ihr euch ja mal
überlegen. Wir gucken jetzt erst
ein paar
Happa Happa Videos.
Onion Burgers.
Gut, das letzte Mal
haben mir ein paar Leute gesagt,
sie wollen gerne noch mal ein paar andere
Essensvideos gucken, als immer
Barbecue Pit Boys, obwohl ich halt gerne
Barbecue Pit Boys gucke.
Habt ihr Vorschläge für gute Essensvideos?
Und ich meine jetzt nicht, irgendwelche
Troll-Essensvideos, wo Leute dann
ekelige Dinge machen, sondern wirklich
Essenvideos,
wo man gutes Essen sieht
und dabei essen kann.
Was gibt es da für schöne Channels?
How to Basic zum Beispiel
schonmal nicht.
How to Basic ist das
ganz garantiert nicht.
Wobei ich How to Basic, ich gucke fast jedes Video.
Ich finde die Dinger übelst geil.
Einfach weil die so gestört sind.
French Guy Cooking.
Okay.
Baguette.
Sagen wir mal hier.
Also.
I made Ramen
from scratch using trash.
Warum use der Trash?
Zucchini peeling.
Oh oui oui.
Starting to get some nice
Starting to get.
Nice.
Von dem, die Ramenvideos von dem
sind ziemlich feifett.
Okay.
Aber was auch immer
cool zu gucken ist.
Satisfying
Egg
Sandwich.
War das glaube ich?
Nee.
Ja doch so was hier.
Wo die teilweise übelstes Tempo vorlegen.
Okay wir gucken.
Skill Share.
Das ist mir fast schon zu französisch.
Ich muss mal kurz Licht anmachen und was
zu trinken einstecken.
One thing I
smell amazing.
Ich mag keine Baguette
wenn ich in der Bar trinke.
Wo wird gekocht
Leute ich will sehen wo gekocht wird.
Easy.
Nee nee ich brauch was wo man permanent
gutes Essen sieht sonst kann ich nicht
futtern dabei.
Ich brauch irgendwas anderes.
Was hatten wir noch für Vorschläge eben gerade?
Travel Thirsty.
Kenn ich nicht.
Was ist das?
Pommes Man.
Fried Nudel Pancake.
Hab ich noch nie was von gehört.
Oh da gehts aber ab hier.
Das klingt doch nach was für mich.
Fertig.
Flamme an.
Das fängt gar nicht erst an zu brennen.
Was ist das denn?
Mark Weins habe ich früher öfters geguckt
allerdings habe ich den Eindruck der ist
mittlerweile überall
cell out in Form von
dass er alles geil findet.
Der sitzt bei jedem
bei dem kleinsten Essen sitzt er da
und macht
ich weiß nicht
mhm
okay zeigen
weil ich wollte
ich wollte so ein Steak essen
deswegen genau, haben wir heute Steaks
deswegen wollen wir heute ein Steaks
und wir machen heute mal noch dazu
ein paar
mit Serranoschinken
machen wir
dann nehmen wir uns mal hier so 4-5 Stück oder was
so, dürft ihr erst dahin hauen
dann haben wir unten das Ende ab
und dann nehmen wir uns
ein schickes Scheiken
danach, danach
wenn wir das geguckt haben
wir müssen noch unbedingt
da kommen wir nicht drum rum
wir müssen noch wieder ein
Kokona BBQ Pit Boys Video gucken
das geht nicht ohne
warum hast du C++
weil C++ eine Krankensprache ist
wenn du es genau wissen willst
ich habe ein riesen Textdokument mittlerweile
weil diese Frage öfters kommt
aber ich bin gerade am futtern
ich gönne dir danach gerne was zu erzählen
ich habe gesagt, weil es eine
Kacksprache ist
wo sich wahrscheinlich das
Standardisierungsgremium
vor jedem
Meeting erstmal die harten Sachen spritzen muss
aber ich weiß nicht wie die andersweitig auf die Idee kommen
erstmal so hauchdünn
geschnitten
dass ich den nicht so ganz
kaputt bekomme
das ist nämlich mein Problem jetzt hier
den wickeln wir jetzt ein
dann haben wir das nämlich, weil das dauert ja eh länger
weil wir das ja schön indirekt grillen wollen
also nicht auf der Flame
die machen wir auch gleich keinen Hexen weg von
einfach mit schönem Olivenöl einwickeln
die Jungs auf den Grill
also eine Sache die ich immer anbringen kann
was ich z.B. ein C++ bis heute nicht verstehen werde ist
warum
hat die
die
die Standard
Stringklasse aus der Standard
Library warum hat die kein
To Upper und To Lower dabei?
warum? das ergibt für mich überhaupt keinen Sinn
es gibt zwar Standard
To Upper und Standard To Lower aber warum ist das
nicht in der Klasse drin?
wozu hat man denn die Klassen wenn man sowas da nicht einbaut?
ist das zu bloated To Upper und To Lower
wollen wir die einfach auf der Feuerplatte drauf
so schönes
Lautstärke sagt
freuen sich auch die Damen immer
ein paar Streus hier
Hauptsache Grünzeug
wir machen das jetzt auch heute mal
also wenn To Upper und To Lower schon zu bloated ist
weil wir für Steaks
einfach nur eine Hölle viel Hitze brauchen
deswegen machen wir auf dem Part jetzt einfach mal die Kohle
damit es richtig heiß wird und auf dem Part machen wir
Holz warum kann ich aus einem Vektor
mit der löschen Methode
wo man einen Index braucht
kein Index angeben sondern muss
iterator beginn plus index
machen auch sowas
man baut alles ein in die Standard
Library und dann ist es eklig zu benutzen
da können wir gleich das Gemüse draufschmeißen weil das brauchen wir nicht ganz so viel
Hitze aber dann haben wir es so ein bisschen getrennt
dann ist es auf einen Seite so richtig
heiß und auf der anderen Seite so ein bisschen heiß
aber dann können wir jetzt gleich die
die Dingens drauf packen
genau das Scheibchen
den Spargel den machen wir jetzt auch schnieke
in Butterschmalz
bald ist es vorbei heiß dass das Update
Zeug funktioniert
alle Schmelze machen hier
da lässt sich nämlich schön hier
dann haben wir auch richtig schön eine Butterschmalz
Note
ja Hitze ist definitiv da
ich will sehen wie das draufgeschmissen wird
Olivenoil
Zeig
also die Steaks würden mir reichen
Spargel
bräuchte ich jetzt nicht
können wir gleich wenn wir die wenden
dann haben wir die richtig schöne Butterschmalz
aber siehst du hier ist auch schon Hitze drauf
deswegen gar nicht so hot machen weil jetzt haben wir
richtig richtig Power Hitze
das wird schon hier
das wird schon das
Butterschmalz
die Steak
die ist schon gut helle heiß das Ding
Swing
wann kommt das Steak drauf
Moment das hab ich verpasst
das geht ja nicht
was genau baust du eigentlich gerade
dass ich meine
ganzen im Haus verteilten Microcontroller
ordentlich über WLAN updaten kann
Firmware updaten machen kann
und zwar nicht nur über HTTP
sondern über HTTPS
HTTP ist überhaupt kein Ding ist total easy
aber über HTTPS muss man
zum größten Teil zumindest das Uploaden
und das verarbeiten das Update selber machen
weil es nichts fertiges gibt
ich hab mir wieder sowas ausgesucht was irgendwie sonst
kein Mensch auf der Welt anscheinend macht
also so ein Steak
wünschen wir jetzt auch reinhauen
sieht da schon mal ganz schnieke aus
in der Zeit wo die in der einen Seite schon mal
ein bisschen ankokelen
und dazu zählt plus plus
und aktuell esse ich was
und danach wieder z plus plus
oder aber je nachdem wie der Chat sich das überlegt
gucken wir uns danach noch ein paar Stellenanzeigen an
weil die eigentliche Update Variante geht ja
was wir jetzt noch machen müssen ist
heute oder morgen
gucken dass wir
die Websockets zum laufen kriegen
gucken dass wir vielleicht diesen
Endlosschleifen Bug in dieser komischen
Web Server Library finden
oder wir gucken uns nachher Stellenanzeigen an
ich kann das auf GitHub packen aber das wird halt einfach so
also ich pack das wenn schon nicht als fertige
fertige Sache
hoch sondern einfach so als Exempel
dass man sich abgucken kann
den Bug hast du gefunden
ich hab vorhin auch mal reingeguckt
ich glaube ich bin auch
halbwegs drauf gekommen woran es liegt
so leicht vor sich hin
noch weiter brutzeln
ne ja nen Server ist jetzt zuviel gesagt
ich hab halt nen Mikrocontroller der
Firmware Updates braucht oder mehrere
und die sind halt in sehr ungünstigen
Stellen so dass ich das nicht per USB
machen kann
das klingt auch schon so leichtfarbe
ich dachte die dauern eh ein bisschen länger aber die will ich auch nicht so in die
in die Hitzezone reinlegen
das klingt auch so leichtfarbe
ich glaube die dauern eh ein bisschen länger aber die will ich auch nicht so in die
in die Hitzezone reinlegen
deswegen
verteilen wir die hier mal so ein bisschen
aber das riecht schon schön
Serrano riecht
das sieht für dich nicht nach C++ das ist richtig
C++ ist hier
aber ich muss auch mal fruttern
einfach nur hölle hölle hölle hölle
heiß hier heißer desto besser
und dann müssen die nur von beiden Seiten aber nur damit die richtig schön
schön Kruste kriegen
aber nur angegrillt werden die Jungs
guck mal sieht man hier von hier
siehst du hier ist noch nicht
dauert noch ne
aber nochmal ein bisschen
was sind das für riesen Salzkörner
das ist noch nicht ganz
die Boys gucken wieder nach
aber es wird es wird
aber es riecht doch schon lecker nach C++
bestimmt irgendeine Meersalzgeschichte
ja siehst du
das würden sie jetzt auch reinhauen
richtig schöne Kruste
hat das im Video gerade geknipst wie ein Fotoapparat
hab ich nicht gehört
und dann können wir die gleich auf Kerntemperatur ziehen
vielleicht Sebao
vielleicht hast du ja auch ein
Fotografier Trojaner bei dir drauf
der Geräusche macht
ach bei der Instagram Einblendung
ich bin am Kauen gerade nebenbei
da hab ich den nicht gehört
ja
okay der Chat beruhigt den Sebao das ist nett
überschüssige Salz weg
dann können wir gleich umdrehen
siehst du guck
einer war das schon
Kruste
ach
zweite Seite
dann können wir noch ein bisschen drehen
wenn der Alkohol jetzt dann verbrannt ist
dann ist das auch wieder alles harmlos
guck mal jetzt hier wie geil die aus sind die Jungs
das sieht echt gut aus
und jetzt ziehen wir die einfach nur da oben hin
weil jetzt müssen wir nur Kerntemperatur haben
einfach aus der Hitze raus
dass wir jetzt nur noch das schicke Aroma haben
und jetzt warten wir einfach praktisch
kann man wenn man kein Temperatur hat
kann man das auch mit dem Handballen messen
also wenn du jetzt hier so hast dann hast du richtig richtig hart
das ist so
wie die Methode kennt sonst einfach Temperatur messen
so ist es recht weich und so wird es immer härter
und so kann man das dann auch letztendlich fühlen
mit der besten Grillzucker in der Welt
wann es dann ready ist
also ein bisschen müssen wir noch
ist schon fast fertig die Jungs
mal gucken
was mein grüner
nicht grüner Daumen was mein Steak Daumen sagt
wie weit wir sind
das ist ja ein riesen Grill
der der Typ hat
könnte das schon
könnte das was geworden sein
ja doch
zwar jetzt ein bisschen well done aber egal
ein bisschen rosa dürfte es sein
aber ich würde es trotzdem sofort fordern
können wir die Steaks nämlich runter nehmen
machen wir da jetzt mal schick
wir brauchen mehr gar nicht
und jetzt
einfach mal
schnick
in kleine Stückchen Schnibbel
so bin ich mal gespannt
jetzt zack
aber es ist auf jeden fall noch gut weich
vom Ding ins her
guck mal
es ist immer noch mega weich
ich mach das sowieso immer gerne
wenn die so weich sind
und
mhm
komm
jetzt wird noch gefuttert
das ist jetzt egal
aber die Dinger sind echt gut aus
so jetzt müssen wir uns nochmal die Kokona Variante davon angucken
wo alles mit
der Machete gemacht wird
Beef Bacon Bagel Burger
das haben wir schon geguckt oder?
haben wir das schon geguckt?
ja
mhm
was haben wir jetzt noch?
Chicken
Chili Chicken
Sub
easy
nachdem es bei uns keinen Sub
mehr gibt
I got my barbecue shoes on
welcome to BBQPitBoys.com
today we're grilling up a chili chicken sub at the pit
and it's real easy to do
all right
for this recipe you're gonna need some chicken breast
some sesame oil, some salt
here we got some paprika
some black pepper, some white pepper
garlic
so viel Grünzeug, was ist denn mit denen los?
nice tomatoes
here we've got a cayenne pepper
Und hier haben wir eine Anaheim Pfeffer, benutze deine Lieblingspfeffer.
Jetzt legen wir das Ganze zusammen. Und ich sage dir, das ist wirklich einfach zu machen.
Du musst das aussehen.
Jetzt kannst du die exakten Ingredienz von dem Handy über die Phoneapps herunternehmen.
Wir haben eine iPhone-App, eine Android-App, die du herunterladen kannst und dann von dort herunter printen.
Aber wir gehen jetzt wieder zurück zu dem, was wir hier tun.
So, jetzt haben wir alle Spieße in die Schale getragen. Und hier sind wir die Weiche von der Weiche separiert.
Wir brauchen die Weiche nicht. Wir wollen die Weiche, um die Spieße zu den Hühnern zu binden.
Einfach genug.
Also wir separieren die Weiche.
Wir nehmen die Weiche für die Bierleute.
Alles klar.
Heute hat er gerade gar nicht seine Machete dabei.
... die Hühnern in der Hälfte. Die machen echt dünn, damit sie schnell kochen. Und sie bleiben echt sauber.
Du siehst, dass diese hübschen Hühnern sehr klein sind.
Sie kommen von diesen neuen Hühnern auf dem Markt.
Sehr, sehr jüngere Hühner.
Sehr, sehr lecker.
Schmeißend, wenn man sie kocht.
Sie sind gut.
Also, sowas.
Wir werfen diese Hühnern in die Schale.
Dann kochen wir sie, wie du sie gerade essen könntest.
Oh Mann. Ich sage dir was.
Es riecht gut.
Kommt gleich, oder?
Ah, doch nicht.
Aber das sagt er sonst immer gerne.
Es riecht gut.
Aber wir sind meistens nach dem Geschmack hier.
Nicht unbedingt, dass es Feuer macht.
Nein, wir wollen keinen Feuer.
Alles klar.
Chili und Pfeffer.
Dann kochen wir die Zwiebeln.
Es kocht nicht, unless es Zwiebeln drin ist.
Alles klar.
Die Zwiebeln sind kocht.
Dann geben wir es einen guten Mix.
Was hat er vor?
Dann braucht er auch keinen Löffel.
Das sind ja riesen Pepperoni.
Was? Hamachi?
Nein, ich kenne nur den ersten Teil.
Das ist lustig.
Ich habe echter Hamachi verstanden.
Den würde ich auch zutrauen, dass sie ihren Motor auslöschen.
Den würde ich auch zutrauen, dass sie ihren Motor ölkrillen.
Brutzeln, brutzeln, brutzeln.
Ich bin gleich fertig essen.
Es ist Zeit, ihn auf den Grill zu nehmen.
Es gibt nichts mehr zu sagen.
Ich schaue einfach.
Es ist Zeit, ihn auf den Grill zu nehmen.
Gena, was soll ich so, Embedded, Embedded, Hardware, Embedded, so haben wir Embedded, Embedded, Hardware, Skill, gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal in Frankfurt, Frankfurt ist immer gut, weil in Frankfurt gibt's viel Kohle.
Ja, okay, aber da sieht man ja gar nicht, was das für Geld gibt, Patrick, das, ähm, das schreibt ja keiner.
Gehalt, okay, also gucken wir mal, Gehalt, Embedded, Hardware, ne, wie, wie, wie kriegt man hier das Gehalt raus, wie, wie, wie kann man da jetzt hin?
Wie kam man denn jetzt zu, wie kam man denn jetzt von, von Hardware-Engineer zu Gehalt?
Ne, also hier stehen bei den wenigsten, wenigsten, ja, guck mal, war das da.
Das ist ja nix, was du da kriegst im Durchschnitt, ja, also für so, für so spezialisierte Leute.
Monk, Woodface, ja, Patrick, da willst du nicht für schaffen hier.
Ja, du bist ja auch in der Schweiz, in der Schweiz, da, dafür ist in der Schweiz auch alles teurer.
So, wie viele Jahre hast du denn Erfahrung, äh, 14, ne, oh, das ist Splatoon, oder?
Nice, ich spiele also überhaupt nicht, aber die Musik finde ich nice.
Also, Erfahrung habe ich 14 Jahre und davon ungefähr, ha, sagen wir mal, sagen wir mal 8 Jahre im DevOps-Bereich als Release-Manager,
ähm, Schrägstrich Code-Reviewer, ich komme ja selbst noch wenig auch zu programmieren aktuell.
Also, ungefähr 8 Jahre kommt hin.
Ja, so in dem Dreh, das ist jetzt schwierig aus dem Kopf zu kriegen.
Hast du überlegt, als Freier zu, äh, als Freier zu arbeiten, Alter?
Äh, ich weiß, was du meinst, ja und ne, also ja, habe ich mir schon überlegt, äh, aber nicht viele Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Ähm, ich bin da auch, ich bin da echt ganz zufrieden, wie es jetzt gerade ist, mein, klar, ähm, mir ist, mir ist auch klar, dass wenn ich wechseln würde,
ich hab ja vor, wann war das, vor 2 Jahren, wo wir hier auch im Stream schon mal geguckt haben,
wo sich danach im Stream auch ein paar Leute gemeldet haben tatsächlich aus Frankfurt, weil ich lustig fand.
Ähm, ich war ein bisschen umgehört und war auch bei einer, bei einer Firma vor Ort.
Ähm, und da, da hättest du gleich instant, instant eine ganze Ecke mehr Kohle gegeben.
Aber, ich bin insofern ganz froh da, wo ich grad bin.
Ähm, ich mein, das Gras ist auf der anderen Seite immer grüner.
Erstens, bist du gekündigt?
Ne, bin ich nicht.
Erstens weißt du, worauf du dich einlässt.
Ich kenn die Leute, ich komm mit den Leuten super klar, ich arbeite nur 4 Tage die Woche.
Und, ähm, insofern, ich verdiene ja noch nebenbei ein bisschen andere Sachen.
Ich hab wirklich aktuell eigentlich kein großes Interesse zu wechseln.
Was machst du immer in der Uhrleiste? Mach mal Ausrufezeichen 1 im Chat.
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen 1. Siehste?
Da unterscheidet sich schon Big Brain zu Small Brain im Chat.
Die coolen Leute schreiben nämlich Ausrufezeichen 1 als Wort.
Ne, da fällt jeder das erste Mal, wenn ich sage Ausrufezeichen 1.
Jeder schreibt Ausrufezeichen, Ausrufezeichen 1, aber muss Ausrufezeichen 1 sein.
Jeder schreibt Ausrufezeichen, Ausrufezeichen 1, aber muss Ausrufezeichen 1 schreiben.
Aber da gibt es eine Erklärung, wo ich das mal versucht hab, ein bisschen genauer zu erklären, warum ich immer 1 tippe.
Im Prinzip ist es ein blöder Angewohnheit von mir.
Der Sebao hat es oben schon eingegeben.
Darf ich mal blöd fragen, was du einem Swiss Admin mit 3 Jahren Erfahrung zur Zeit empfehlen wirst?
Boah, ich bin echt nicht der Beste, was da drin irgendwie eine Jobadvice ist, irgendwie zu geben.
Ich mein, ich hab jetzt in 14 Jahren ungefähr einmal meinen Job gewechselt.
Also, ich hab meine Ausbildung gemacht bei einem Provider.
Und jetzt bin ich, dann bin ich dahin gewechselt, wo ich jetzt bin.
Jetzt bin ich immer noch.
Also, letztens gab es noch wieder ein bisschen mehr Kohle.
Also so, nicht nur wegen dem Tarifvertrag.
Das heißt, da bin ich ab und zu mal am Nerven.
Aber ich bin da glaube ich da falsch in den krassen Ratschlägen.
Zumal das eh extrem davon abhängig ist, in welcher Region du bist.
Und wie es aktuell gerade mit der ganzen Corona-Geschichte aussieht, kann ich dir erst recht nicht sagen.
Ich weiß, dass zum Beispiel unsere Externen gerade ein bisschen hibbelig sind, was das angeht.
Weil es wohl gerade schlechte Aussichten gibt.
Was Jobs angeht.
Wobei ich mir halt immer denke, dass wenn du dich in einem Bereich wirklich gut auskennst,
und das ist ein Bereich, der auch gefragt ist, gerade in so einem Gebiet wie Israel-Main-Gebiet oder Frankfurt,
da wirst du wahrscheinlich immer irgendwas finden.
Achso, in welche Richtung man sich spezialisieren könnte.
Grundlegend würde ich sagen, was du dich fragen musst ist,
willst du eher, also nein, drei Sachen musst du dich einfragen.
Sind Führungspositionen und irgendwelche Projektmanagement-Geschichten was für dich.
Und wenn du bei der Technik bleiben willst, wirst du immer etwas finden.
Also willst du Entwickler werden oder willst du eher in Richtung DevOps, Cloud und sonst was gehen.
Wobei Cloud für beides gilt.
Wenn man jetzt mal von meinem Bereich ausgeht.
Also wenn ich da jemandem was empfehlen würde.
Weil angenommen, du hättest jetzt frisch Fachinformatiker, Systemintegration oder sowas gelernt,
dann hättest du ja auch ein bisschen mehr Erfahrung.
Und willst du in den Bereich aussuchen, dich zu spezialisieren.
Da würde ich sagen als erstes,
überleg mal, was dir an sich gefällt.
Also sprich, was machst du gerne, was interessiert dich auch privat.
Weil es ist ätzend, wenn man sich mit Sachen beschäftigen muss, wo man keinen Bock drauf hat.
Und das ist so ein Problem.
Also sprich, wenn du dich mit was auskennst, was dich interessiert, dann wirst du mit der Zeit auch immer besser.
Weil es dich eben interessiert, nicht nur auf der Arbeit und auch privat.
Und dadurch steigen wiederum die Chancen, dass du in dem Bereich arbeiten kannst, der dich interessiert.
Und dadurch wirst du wieder besser in dem Bereich, wo du dich interessierst.
Und das ist auch ein Problem.
Und dadurch steigen wiederum die Chancen, dass du in dem Bereich arbeiten kannst, der dich interessiert.
Und dadurch wirst du wieder besser in dem Bereich und du hast noch bessere Chancen, in dem Bereich wieder was zu finden, zu arbeiten.
Aber allgemein gesagt, was zur Zeit angesagt ist, sind jegliche Cloud-Geschichten.
Also wenn du dich jetzt erstmal durch die Bank legst, egal ob es jetzt Azure ist, oder ob es AWS ist,
Google, wie heißt die Google Cloud Services nochmal?
Ob es Google ist?
Das ist jetzt erstmal, ja, nicht so wild, GCP, genau.
Das ist auch sehr firmenspezifisch, was die dann einsetzen.
Aber Cloud ist eindeutig ein Thema.
Cloud in Kombination mit Container und da allem vorweg Kubernetes.
Das ist so der Bereich, der gerade voll angesagt ist.
Wenn du hippe Technologien lernen willst.
Cloud, Kubernetes, Container.
Was ist Kubernetes überhaupt, fragt der Sebao.
Das ist ein Container-Orchestrierungs-Software.
Ist Serverless noch in?
Ja, ja, das gehört alles zu Serverless.
Oder, oder, da gibt es so viele Buzzwords.
Cloud ist ja mittlerweile schon Mainstream.
Serverless, dann gibt es noch Function as a Service, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Im Prinzip ist das alles nur Buzzword-Bullshit.
Serverless ist nicht Serverless, totaler Blödsinn.
Das einzige, was Serverless ist, ist vielleicht dein Rechenzentrum.
Aber irgendwo steht immer noch ein Server, der den Kram ausliefert.
Also Serverless ist genau das Gegenteil von Serverless.
Kann man damit viele VMs deployen, die alle vorkonfiguriert sind, oder wie?
Nee, keine VMs.
Du kannst es vielleicht ein bisschen so vorstellen wie VMs, aber...
Es sind nicht wirklich eigenständige VMs.
Es sind eigene Prozesse in so einer Art Sandbox.
Also sprich, der Unterschied, wenn du unter Linux jetzt einfach ein Programm startest,
und ob du das jetzt in einem Container-Unterlienung startest, ist gar kein so großer Unterschied.
Das ist nach wie vor auf dem gleichen Host, im gleichen Kern, ein weiterer Prozess.
Der Unterschied zwischen einem normal gestarteten Prozess und einem quasi containerisierten Prozess ist,
dass der seine eigenen Libraries und quasi eigene User-Space mitbringt
und ein bisschen Sandbox-Sachen drumherum hat,
die ihn ein bisschen abkapseln vom Host und von anderen Prozessen.
Nicht so sehr, wie es eine VM macht.
Du hast beispielsweise halt kein virtualisiertes File-System,
du hast kein virtualisiertes Netzwerk oder sonst was in der Richtung.
Was natürlich den Vorteil hat im Vergleich zu einer VM,
du kriegst deutlich mehr Container auf die Hardware drauf als VMs.
Nicht so sehr von der CPU, sondern eher vom RAM-Verbrauch.
CPU-Performance ist jetzt in einer VM zu dem Host...
Es ist kein allzu großer Unterschied.
Guck mal, ich habe hier meine VM laufen mit 8 GB RAM.
Theoretisch könnte ich 16 reinmachen.
Die andere VM habe ich auch 16, 4 CPU-Kern von 6.
Und die Performance in der VM ist absolut native.
Du merkst keinen Unterschied dazwischen, zwischen VM und Host-CPU.
CPU wohlgemerkt.
Wo du was merkst, ist natürlich bei Grafikausgabe und Video-Decoding,
weil du das nicht über die Grafika machen kannst in der VM.
Aber die reine CPU-Performance ist zwischen VM und Host kaum ein Unterschied.
Nehmt sich nichts.
Der große Unterschied zwischen...
Das, was du wirklich sparst bei Containern, ist RAM.
Weil VMs brauchen verhältnismäßig viel RAM,
weil alles virtualisiert werden muss, eigenes Betriebssystem, eigener Kernel, der läuft.
Dafür sind VMs halt besser isoliert gegenüber Containern.
Ganz grober Rundumschlag jetzt.
Ausgelagerter Server gleich Serverless.
Serverless ist absolut nicht Serverless.
Das ist eh so ein Thema, da kann ich mich Stunden drüber auslassen.
Du schleppst immer ein komplettes Betriebssystem mit.
Unabhängig davon, Sebaro muss man sagen, auch wenn gerade Containerisieren voll der heiße Shit ist,
hast du schon mal was mit Docker und Stream gemacht.
Ich glaube schon.
Jaja, öfters mal schon.
Nicht unbedingt Docker als hauptsächliches Thema, sondern halt um Sachen auszuprobieren.
Nichtsdestotrotz darf man eine Sache nicht vergessen.
Man sollte immer das nehmen, was passt.
Ich meine aktuell ist halt Kubernetes, Cloud, Container, Krichten voll angesagt,
aber es hat überhaupt keinen Sinn, wenn man daheim was kleines laufen lassen will,
da jetzt mit großartigem Containerisierungszeug anzufangen.
Also irgendwie Raspberry Pi, Kubernetes Cluster oder so abgedrehte Sachen.
Es ist vollkommen okay, wenn man darauf scheißt und zwei Services auf einer Lidungskiste daheim bei sich startet.
Ohne gänzlich, ohne jegliche Container, ohne VMs, ohne Docker, ohne Kubernetes, ohne alles.
Man muss immer gucken, was angemessen ist.
Und wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel eine Firewall in der VM laufen lassen will,
dann würde ich das auf jeden Fall in der VM machen und nicht in einem Container, weil es da auf Isolierung ankommt.
Also man muss gucken, dass man das nimmt, was für die jeweilige Aufgabe passt.
Nextlot war doch im Docker Onstream, ich glaube schon, ja.
So, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Okay, die Bahn sucht Leute, das hat man schon gehört.
Full Stack Engineering.
Okay, da verstehe ich eigentlich so...
Full Stack ist für mich eher Richtung Programmierer, aber gucken wir mal, was da steht.
Oh, krasse Business-Fotos.
Sebaro, das ist ein typischer Fall von, man sollte es so machen, wie es am besten funktioniert für einen.
Man darf sich nicht so sehr durch irgendwelche Hype-Technologien aufschwätzen lassen, wie man Sachen macht.
Wenn das für dich die einfachste Variante ist und die günstigste Variante, dann nimm zwei Server, fertig.
In den Größenordnungen spricht ja da auch überhaupt nichts dagegen.
Wenn du jetzt auf diesen Server Nummer Nummer als Beispiel für, wo sich sowas lohnen kann.
Im Angenommen, du hast eine Web-Anwendung, wo du... Was machst du denn da drüber?
Wo die Leute Konzerte buchen... Nee, Konzerte buchen ist scheiße.
Fitness, du hast eine Fitness-Web-Anwendung.
Corona, du hast eine Corona-Fitness-App.
Die App ist unterschiedlich stark frequentiert.
Je nachdem, wie viele Leute gerade Corona haben, wie viele Leute Fitness... Wie das Wetter ist.
Wenn das Wetter gut ist, machen viele Leute Fitness draus.
Du hast viel mehr Daten aufkommen, als wenn das Wetter schlecht ist.
Da ist es ganz praktisch, wenn du das so weit modular hast und das in irgendeiner Cloud-Container-Orgestrierung laufen hast.
Da kannst du relativ einfach sagen, heute ist gutes Wetter.
Ich weiß, heute kommt der Ansturm und du skalierst das schon mal im Vorfeld hoch.
Dass du sagst, wir gehen jetzt von 8 Containern auf 32 oder so.
Oder aber noch besser, du hast Load Balancer davor, du machst das dynamisch.
Also sprich, sobald die Kisten über eine gewisse Auslastungsschwelle drüber gehen, kannst du einfach hochskalieren.
Das ist natürlich eine Sache, das machst du mit VMs und gar Hardware nicht so leicht.
Aber das bringt dir natürlich nur erst was, wenn dann bei einer gewissen Größe.
Was mich hier schon mal abschreckt, ist, die sehen alle so ultra-Business-mäßig aus mit Anzug und so.
Das Xenoplank-Musik, ja.
Der Rollout von Pokemon Go, ja genau, sowas zum Beispiel.
Oder irgendein Launch von irgendeinem Game oder ein Addon, ein neues Spiele-Addon-Lounge.
Erstmal ein Login-Server hochfahren von 20 auf 300.
Okay, Union Investment, sind das nicht die, sind das die nicht mit den Checks?
Ah nee, das ist Western Union, was habe ich jetzt?
Also, ist der Experte für Vorvermögensverwaltung in der Genossenschaftsgruppe?
Es ist natürlich enorm wichtig, dass ich das sofort mal erzählt kriege, ja.
Ähm...
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Blah, blah.
Gut, vollkommen uninteressant.
Hier...
Hierin schreibt man das echt so?
Tatsächlich.
Hier, hierin sind...
Exquisite-Wortwahl.
Excellent.
Okay, als Default speziell für digitale Prozesse rund um die Gelabla, blabla, blabla, blabla, blabla.
Koordinieren Sie in einem cross-funktionalen, agilen Team die technisch und inhaltliche Verfügbarkeit,
sowie Stabilität für Umgebung, gemeinsam mit dem 1015 gegründeten...
Der Name kommt mir bekannt vor.
Der Name kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
Sind die nicht bei uns in Frankfurt um die Ecke?
Irgendwie kommt mir der Name übelst bekannt vor.
Ja!
Hauptbahnhof, die sind hier bei uns um die Ecke.
Der Name kommt mir übelst bekannt vor.
Ich glaube, da sind manche, ein paar Mexikaner bei uns am Futtern.
Irgendwie kommt mir der Name echt bekannt vor.
Ich weiß nicht, woher.
Irgendwie kommt mir der Name bekannt vor.
Oh, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt geht es ab hier.
Wir wollen zurzeit ein dediziertes Testsystem pro Branche hochfahren lassen.
Das klingt natürlich sehr sinnvoll.
Und jetzt, jetzt kommt es hier.
Nur leider ist die Architektur nicht dafür ausgelegt.
gelegt, müssten dafür einen dedizierten Hadoop-Mini-Cluster jedes Mal hochfahren.
Exzellent!
So, ähm, also das ist jetzt, äh, was haben wir sonst noch hier? Schönes.
Verantwortung für Bildpipeline, sicherstell, bla bla bla, Release und Deploy, okay.
Das ist, das ist alles so langweilig geschrieben irgendwie.
Schnittstelle zwischen, ja, Zustände für das Monitoren, ja, okay, Konzeption.
Ja, gut.
Dahinter stehen sie als Mensch.
Berufserfahrung als DevOps-Engineer oder Software-Entwickler idealerweise im Finanzumfeld.
Na Leute, das wäre ja wie die Faust aufs Auge für mich, oder?
Das ist ja, da trifft ja, da trifft ja alles.
Also das ist ja schon, äh, optimaler kann es denn immer sein.
Äh, Max suchst du? Nein, mach ich nicht. Ich guck einfach nur, was es gibt.
Hauptsächlich, um mich ein bisschen, äh, abzulästern über Stellenanzeigen.
Aber die ist, über die Stellenanzeige kann man nicht mal abzulästern.
Die finde ich einfach nur ein bisschen langweilig irgendwie.
Continuous Delivery Integration, sowohl in methodischer als auch in technologischer Hinsicht.
Jenkins Nexus Run Deck, guck mal da.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es Leute gibt, die mögliche Run Deck verwenden.
Nexus Deutet schon mal darauf hin, dass es Java ist.
Dubiosas Deck, das gehört auch nicht wirklich zusammen, muss man sagen.
Na wobei, doch, so blöd, so blöd ist das gar nicht.
Nexus, das ist für Java, fertige Java-Anwendung.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich hab bis heute nicht genau gecheckt, wofür Nexus eigentlich da ist.
Ich glaube, da sind irgendwelche fertigen Java-Bilds werden da drin verwaltet.
Das ist jetzt irgendwie ein Java-Gedöns auf jeden Fall.
Jenkins als Job-Bild, was auch immer Server.
Und Run Deck, um das fertig Gebildete zu deployen.
Garantiert, könnte ich wetten.
Ja, also.
Ahh, das können wir uns gerne algucken, wenn du das rausrücken willst.
Jenkins kann auch deployen. Natürlich kann Jenkins deployen.
Alleins schon weil Jenkins beliebige Bash Befehle ausführt kann oder alles mögliche ausführt.
Aber ich vermute, die verwenden Run Deck nicht wirklich.
declaring
kann oder alles mögliche ausführen, aber ich vermute die verwenden Rundeck zum Deployen, weil ansonsten würde Rundeck keinen Sinn machen.
Also ich denke mal hier ist das Java Zeug drinnen, hier werden die Sachen gebaut und vielleicht gegen irgendwas getestet und hier wird's deploit.
So sehr gute Kenntnisse in Linux, Unix, Java, muss das sein.
Java Enterprise sowie Konfiguration von Wildfly und JBoss. Wildfly hab ich keine Ahnung was das ist, wahrscheinlich irgendein Application Server.
JBoss ist ein Application Server, Nginx ist ein Web Server.
Erfahrung in Scripting, Markup, Bash, Pryzen, Jaml, SQL, Postgres, passt alles. Kenntnisse in Hira oder, oh sorry Leute, Hira, ich hab's, tut mir leid ich hab's korrekt ausgesprochen.
Jira, natürlich. Jira, Jira, Chira. Also offiziell heißt es Hira, nur mal um das nochmal klarzustellen an der Stelle, ja.
Schon arbeitslos durch Corona, nee. Wildfly ist der Open Source JBoss, aha. Hier lernt man auch was, Chat. Hier, hier ist, hier lernt man auch was.
Also Hira, Jenkins, Nagiosse. Also es sind keine wirklich Nagiosse, es sind irgendwann mal Nagiosse gewesen. Git, Bitbucket, Wildfly, Keycloak, Puppet, Angular.
WTF, ohne Scheiß, diese Stellenanzeige passt zu 90% wie die Force of's Auge bei mir. Jetzt mal das ganze Java Zeug außen vor, aber der ganze andere Kram.
Ich mag Nagiosse Leute, ich hab's euch schon ein paar mal erzählt. Aber ich bin vorbelastet was Nagiosse angeht, ich mag Nagiosse.
Ich weiß viele Leute sagen Nagiosse. Geh mal fort, ich mag Nagiosse.
Analytische Fähigkeiten gepaart mit einer kommunikativen und integrativen Person. Was soll ich mir denn darunter vorstellen? Das ist so ein typischer Personalsatz, oder?
Was zum Teufel soll das sein? Anna, das können die dir wahrscheinlich selber nicht erklären, wenn du sie fragst.
Stonk Sentence. Nagiosse war ein Abschlussprojekt in der Schule, sehr nice. Mein Abschlussprojekt damals bei der Ausbildung war ein OpenVPN, Layer 2 OpenVPN.
Analytische Fähigkeiten gepaart mit einer kommunikativen und integrativen Persönlichkeit. Das heißt, jemand der gut mit Leuten reden kann und der sich in bestehende Sachen einfügen kann oder sowas.
Sehr gute Deutschkenntnisse in Wort und Schrift sowie gute Englischkenntnisse. Ja, meine absolut exzellenten Englischkenntnisse habe ich ja schon öfters im Stream unter Beweis gestellt, da muss ich ja nichts mehr sagen.
Das ist ja über jeden Zweifel erhaben, haben wir schon öfters gehört hier. Neben einer überdurchschnittlichen sowie leistungsorientierten Vergütung erhalten sehr viele...
Förderung der beruflichen Weiter...ja gut, das ist ja auch das Interesse dran von denen. Brauchst du Englisch bei der Arbeit? Ich hab nicht umsonst alles bei mir auf Englisch stehen, jegliche Browser, jegliche Sachen.
Das Einzige, was ich auf Deutsch hab, ist auf meinem Rechner das Tastaturlayout. Achso, du meinst Englisch mit Leuten reden? Eher just for fun? Also es reden eigentlich alle Deutsch, aber wir haben zwei Amis, wir haben ein paar Engländer.
Also paar Schnipsel immer zwischendurch, so ein bisschen aus Spaß, aber jetzt nicht wirklich lang. Und ich brauche auch immer ein bisschen, bis ich reinkomme. Hat man vor allem bei der Gamescom immer gemerkt, so ein ersten Tag ist übelst das Gestammel.
Aber wenn man sich dran gewöhnt hat, geht's. Flexibles Arbeit, Fahrtkosten zu Jobticket, Angebot zur Betrieblicherverwaltung. Unterstützungsangebote für Kinderbetreuung, das finde ich mal gut, dass das jemand reinschreibt.
Das finde ich mal gut, dass das jemand reinschreibt, wenn er es hat, weil das ist ein echter Vorteil. Je nachdem wie die Unterstützungsangebote aussehen. Aber für Leute, die die Kinder haben und teilweise auch nicht wissen wohin und keinen Platz kriegen, was auch immer, ist das wirklich nicht schlecht.
Check Zipgate aus, der steil hängst du da. Hatten wir doch schon mal, hatten wir doch schon mal. Zipgate Jobs, hatten wir doch schon mal. Nee, nicht SPgate. Zipgate, haben wir uns doch schon mal angeguckt. So, ich guck den grad nochmal fertig hier.
Da gucken wir Zipgate. Sportangebote, Mittagessen, Kantine. Leute, ich hätte nicht für möglich gehalten, wie gut das ist, wenn man, also einmal natürlich Mittagessen Zuschuss kriegt, aber wenn man eine Kantine im Haus hat.
Weil man denkt, man denkt sich immer so, immer wieder jeden Tag ins gleiche und es ist doch kacke, aber es ist viel besser. Man ist einfach sofort da, kann essen und wieder zurück.
Ansonsten musst du 45 Minuten oder so am Tag länger auf der Arbeit bleiben. Einfach nur durch das hin und zurück und das Mittagessen und alles drum herum. Das ist voll Fünasch. Und eine Kantine ist das beste, was es gibt.
Es ist genau als erstens nicht viel teurer als drum herum. Bei uns gibt es zum Beispiel kostenloses Trinken, was du bei keinem anderen Restaurant in der Umgebung kriegst. Und du bist halt sofort da, kannst essen und gehst wieder rein und bist am Start.
Also Kantine lohnt sich wirklich. Mitarbeiterrabatte. Also ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, die Anzeige finde ich gar nicht schlecht. Die Anzeige finde ich gar nicht schlecht.
Ja, Java ist das Problem, aber das ist das, was mich abschreckt. Aber ernsthaft, macht echt keinen schlechten Eindruck hier.
So ok, Zipgate. Wir gucken jetzt Zipgate an. Also Zipgate. Übersicht. 13 offene Jobs.
Was haben wir zu bieten? Full Stack Entwickler. In. Such bei der Bahn. Haben wir das letzte Mal schon? Was ist deine Lieblingssprache? Also wenn ich komplett, also wenn sich der Einsatzzweck dafür eignet und wenn ich wirklich komplett machen kann, weil ich will.net.
Also C-Sharp. C-Sharp ist meine absolut Lieblingssprache und.NET Core mittlerweile auch meine absolut Lieblingsplattform. Aber es sei denn, es ist wirklich irgendwas, wo es nicht geht.
Ich weiß ja Patrick, für den ist C die all das einzig wahre. Eventuell noch Assembler. Könnt ihr euch noch an den Stream erinnern, wo wir mal auf dem ESP286, wo wir Assembler programmiert haben. Boah, das sind Rots.
Benutzt das.NET und lässt das über Java? Natürlich,.NET ist auch besser. Why do Java Developers wear classes?
Okay, der ist so schlecht und schon so oft gebracht, dass es Payne's Champ ist, muss ich sagen. Go, doch. Go habe ich, diese Videoüberwachungsgeschichte, die ich für meine Kameras gebastelt habe, die ist ja eine Mischung aus, die erste Version war eine Mischung aus Go und C.
Allerdings war der Interop von Go und C so abartig, dass ich das jetzt zum größten Teil in C-Sharp neu gebastelt habe. Mit ein bisschen Go, da komme ich nicht drum herum.
Ja, Rust ist nice. Aber ich muss den Patrick in sofern schon recht geben, C ist eine super Sprache. Du weißt in der Regel immer was passiert, was man bei anderen Sprachen nicht wirklich sagen kann.
Ich meine, guckt euch den C++-Crap hier an manchen Stellen an, den wir vorher hatten, wo du keinen blassen Schimmer hast, warum manche Sachen nicht erlaubt sind und warum manche Sachen gehen.
Das Problem hast du bei C nicht, bei C geht erstmal nix. Außer es geht. Und dann geht's. Das ist ja das Schöne an C, C kann nix im Endeffekt. C hat außer den Basics nix, aber die funktionieren halt gut.
Das ist nicht schlimm. Du kannst ja in C alles machen. Du kannst ja in C komplett alles machen. C++ ist historisch gewachsen. Ich weiß nicht, was mit dem Standard-Cremium los ist. Es leuchtet mir echt nicht ein.
Die basteln an so vielen Sachen rum und machen die Sachen so unnötig kompliziert in C++. Also ich meine, wenn allein schon eine Feature-Ankündigung...
Wir haben uns ja letztens mal diese Feature-Ankündigung für C++, C++20, dieses, der Patrick weiß es vielleicht noch, was hatten wir uns da angeguckt?
Irgendwelche Templates, Covariants, blablabla. Irgendwas ganz merkwürdiges. Also wenn du schon die Feature-Ankündigung mit Beispielen, drei Seiten brauchst und am Ende absolut keinen Schimmer hast, was die Feature-Ankündigung eigentlich ankündigt, dann stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Vor allem, dass mal wieder zig Zeichen doppelt belegt sind. Teilweise Zeilenumbrüche an Stellen sind, wo du denkst, was macht da jetzt ein Zeilenumbruch drin?
Dass manche Sachen doppelt und dreifach belegt sind. Aber wenn ich die Sachen bei C++ sehe, kriege ich echt immer Anfälle.
C++ ist Elite aus diesem Grund kompliziert. Aha, verstehe, verstehe. Der Chief schreibt, C ist halt Müll, was Stack Overflows betrifft. Ist ganz einfach. Keine Stack Overflows prokommieren. Eats.
Easy. Easy. Easy. Easy as f**k. Und wenn nicht, crashs halt. Ja, das ist natürlich ein Problem, aber man kann halt irgendwie nicht alles haben.
Man kann nicht eine Sprache haben, die möglichst minimal und aus dem Weg geht und quasi mehr oder weniger eins zu eins ein bisschen Abstraktion über ganz Low Level ist.
Mit der man dann auch maximale Performance haben will. Das beißt sich so ein bisschen.
Bei Rust, Rust ist ja eine Sprache, die hätte ich so früher persönlich nicht für möglich gehalten. Weil ich hätte halt immer gesagt, okay, wenn du es komfortabler haben willst und wenn du es sichere haben willst, dann hast du es halt auch nicht mehr ganz so Low und du hast vor allem ein bisschen langsamer.
Logischerweise. Zum Beispiel, was ist die, musst du eigentlich morgen arbeiten? Ja, aber ich habe ja Homeoffice. Das heißt, ich kann auch mal kurz sein. Das heißt, du hast dann zwei Varianten.
Entweder, um jetzt mal beim Thema Overflows zu bleiben, entweder machst du vor jedem Zugriff einen Overflow-Check. Das ist langsamer, aber sicher. Oder nicht. Und dann bist du wieder bei C.
Deswegen hätte ich sowas wie Rust früher nicht für möglich gehalten. Rust macht das eigentlich super clever.
Rust erkennt quasi zur Kompilzeit, ob das, was du programmiert hast, zu 99% das, was du programmiert hast und bevor es nicht erkennt, kackt es eher ab und sagt, darfst du nicht kompilieren.
Erkennt zur Kompilzeit, ob dein Code so programmiert ist, dass es überhaupt zu Overflows kommen kann.
Also so nach dem Motto, der Thread läuft noch weiter, obwohl du eigentlich schon rausgehst und solche Dinge. Das checken die alles.
Das ist eine Sache, die hätte ich bevor es Rust gegeben hat gar nicht für möglich gehalten.
Weil das ist, wenn man so will, die optimale Kombination aus Performance, Sicherheit und auch teilweise Komfort. Das Problem ist nur bei Rust, weil irgendein Tot musste sterben.
Das Problem bei Rust ist, da ist zwar alles andere toll, aber Rust ist echt kompliziert, bis man da mal reinkommt.
Ich nenne es jetzt Cobol. Cobol ist die zukunftssichere Sprache. Nur so halb Kappa, weil Cobol-Entwickler wird es immer geben.
Ruby ist auch toll. Ruby mag ich. Ruby ist neben C Sharp meine zweite Lieblingssprache.
Leider gibt es nicht mehr so viele Varianten, gerade Ruby zu verwenden. Rails ist im Arsch. Verwendet keiner mehr, auch wenn es immer noch ein ganz cooles Framework ist.
Linux-Seitig-Scripting ist eigentlich 90% Bash und wenn keiner Bock auf Bash hat, dann ist es Python. Ruby eigentlich so gut wie nie.
Pearl verwendet auch kein Sau mehr. Es gibt leider gerade wenig Anwendungsgebiete für Ruby. Auch wenn ich es blöd finde, weil Ruby ist eine super Sprache.
Die haben Sonderzeichen ihrer Syntax, von denen du bis dahin nicht mehr wusstest, dass die gibt, richtig. So sieht es halt in C++ aus. In Rust allerdings ist auch nicht ganz sonderzeichenfrei.
Arbeit. Arbeitsverkennst du Ansible? Ja. Kenne ich. Habe ich auch schon ein bisschen mit was gemacht. Finde ich das eine super Geschichte. Arbeit nicht. Da haben wir eine uralt Puppet-Base für die Konfics. Also uralt, die wird immer noch aktiv weiter verwendet und gepflegt.
GitLab ist doch Ruby. Früher war es das? Jetzt weiß ich nicht. Früher war GitLab eine Rails-Anwendung.
Aber abwärts geht es los. Und wie ist es mit Terraform? Ist das dieses Haschikorp-Terraform-Ding? Die hat noch so einen komischen Namen.
Haschikorp. Haschikorp. Nicht großartig.
Ich weiß, dass es ein Tool ist, was du quasi nicht die Sachen aufbaust und hinstellst, sondern dass du Konfig-Dateien erstellst, die das Terraform für dich, die Kisten, so hinstellt.
Infrastructure-Escode. Genau. Ja, da steht es. Habe ich aber noch nicht viel mitgemacht.
Choose my name. Fünf Monate. Danke schön. Huge. Danke schön. So, wir gucken jetzt aber auch schnell über die Angebote von Zipgate drüber, weil wir sollen ja mal drüber gucken, Zipgate. Also nichts dabei, bewirbt sich trotzdem. Kinderbetreuung, NRW oder Produkt oder...
Was für ein Ding. Holistische. Was? Holistische? Ich weiß ja nicht mal, was das ist. Ja, alles gut, Zwiebelgeist.
Zombie Bear Games. Twitch Prime. Dankeschön. Ich habe bestimmt jede Menge Subs heute wieder übersehen, weil ich vorher so mal im Progress konzentriert war. Guck noch mal rein, wen haben wir denn da hier noch?
Oh, ich habe sie alle. Ich habe sie alle. Also ich habe keine Ahnung, Holistische. Designerin, Webdigital, UX-Designer, Produktdesignerin, Voice, Software-Engineer, Plattform-Foundation, Fullstack-Entwickler.
Okay, gucken wir mal, was Zipgate da so am Start hat. Wir suchen dich. Fullstack-Entwickler. In.
Deine Arbeit möchtest du nicht über den Zaun geworfen bekommen und stattdessen ein neues Feature von der Konzentration bis zum Release und darüber hinaus begleiten.
Endlich mal eine ordentliche Einleitung. Nicht so diese Geschichte, wir sind führend im Bereich von Voice-Over-IP-Kommunikation und bla bla bla bla, sondern einfach mal geschrieben, was Sache ist.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es dir als Video gut eignet. Machst du momentan andere Tätigkeiten beim Job wegen der Corona? Nö. Die Polizei herrschen kann ich gleich machen. Mach ich nicht, mach genau das gleiche wie vorher.
Es ist bei uns auch gerade eher noch mehr los als sonst. Gerade weil lustigerweise unser Außendienst jetzt gerade nach anderen Möglichkeiten sucht, Dinger zu verkaufen.
Okay, JavaScript und Java sind keine Fremdsprachen für dich und gehen dir fluffig von der Hand. Java muss es sein.
Du kannst problemlos an einem Tag tief in CSS am nächsten Tag in MySQL einsteigen.
Oder was ich damit machen soll am Ende. Ich würde nicht von mir behaupten, dass ich innerhalb von einem Tag mich so tief in eine Technologie einarbeiten kann, dass ich damals produktionsreifes fabrizieren kann.
Und jeder, der das behauptet, wird früher oder später Mist zusammen basteln.
Java gleich C-Sharp, change my mind. Ja, Java 4 Buchstaben, C-Sharp 2 Buchstaben. Das ist schon mal ganz einfach.
Zusammen mit deinem Team liebst du es, die volle Verantwortung für ein Produkt zu haben, bist begeistert, wenn Kundinnen deine Arbeit so veranstalten.
Ich muss manchmal immer noch über diese Schreibweise lachen. Man muss halt korrekt sein.
Man kann nicht einfach so neutral schreiben, begeistert, wenn Kunden, also es müssen Kundinnen sein.
Dein Wissen gibst du außerdem gerne weiter und weißt, dass man nie ausnimmt. Da haben sie Recht.
Dann bewirb dich jetzt. Okay, unser Technologie-Stack, JavaScript, Node.js, React, Redux, Yarn.
Die sich übrigens gerade bei Yarn selbst ins eigene Fleisch schneiden mit Yarn 2. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das mitgekriegt habt.
Die haben jetzt die zweite Version von ihrem Paketmanager rausgebracht, der nicht richtig kompatibel zur Version 1 ist.
Und Sachen standard gesetzt hat, die die Hälfte der JavaScript-Pakete unbrauchbar macht. Ganz merkwürdig, was da abgeht.
Also, ja, ja. Nee, habe ich wenig bisher mitgemacht. Ich bin ja eher der Vue.js-Man.
Das eher. Okay, Wildfly scheint voll angesagt zu sein.
Wert X sagt mir 0. Basierende Java-Micro-Services, die wir per Rest und Enterprise-Message-Bus verfügen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was der Enterprise-Message-Bus ist, aber ist bestimmt irgendwas mit Java.
Außerdem arbeiten wir noch mehrere Perl und Java. Oh, Perl. Da sind sie aber exquisite unterwegs mittlerweile.
Man hat ja früher immer gesagt, Perl ist so die einzige write-only-Programmiersprache.
Zusätzlich integrieren wir SIPgen andere Produkte und setzen dazu die APIs der Anbieter, zum Beispiel Google oder Salesforce.
Was? Ah, und nutzen dazu die. Okay. Wir stehen auf clean code und haben einen eigentlichen Code-Style,
den wir viel diskutieren, den wir gemeinsam... Das ist nicht übel, wobei ich ja jemand bin,
der dann immer der Meinung ist, dass das am allerlogischsten ist, so wie ich das mache,
und ich mich dann wahrscheinlich erst mal ärgere, dass ich das nicht so machen wollen wie ich.
Aber da kann ich mit leben. Da kann ich mit leben, ja. Ich habe da auch keine Schmerzen, das anders zu machen.
Man codet so wie Standard-Library. Der Ada ist sich selbst nicht bei Microsoft einig. Gerade bei C-Sharp hast du zwei Fraktionen.
Du hast die, die Klassen, also private Variablen, mit underscore machen oder die es nicht mit underscore machen
und dann this davor schreiben, um zu kennzeichnen, dass es eine private Klassenvariable ist.
Und du hast beides bei Microsoft. Sogar in den offiziellen Beispielen hast du beides.
Der Style Guide bei Microsoft sagt meiner Meinung nach, dass man kein underscore verwendet, sondern private Klassenvariablen,
Member, wie auch immer, kleinschreibt. In den Beispielen haben sie oftmals aber underscore.
Ryder hat standardmäßig underscore gemacht. Ich finde es mittlerweile auch gut. Ihr erkennt es noch.
Ihr könnt euch vielleicht noch dran erinnern, so vor ein, zwei Jahren, wo man dort, wo ich die Sachen in C-Sharp gemacht habe,
da habe ich immer this und klein geschrieben. Mittlerweile bin ich auch ein Fan von underscore.
Was kann man mit den Keksen machen? Du kannst sie ausgeben für sinnlose Sachen, wie zum Beispiel,
dass du in einem Emote eine Sonnenbrille aufsetzen kannst, zum Beispiel.
Sieht dann so aus. Oder die Nachricht hervorheben kannst oder sowas.
Du hast fast 20K. Boah, ich habe unendlich. Aber nur bei mir auf dem Channel.
Aber die Stellenanzeige finde ich nicht schlecht. Wenigstens ist kein Ultra-Selbstbeweihräucherung am Anfang.
Okay, ich komme jetzt aber schnell in die Polizei Hessen und dann ist es vorbei für heute.
Also was will denn die Polizei Hessen? Dualer Studio mit Schwerpunkt Cybercrime.
Dualer Studio will ich nicht machen. Bringe Licht ins Darknet.
Wetten, dass das alles keine Polizisten sind hier auf dem Bild, sondern irgendwelche Models, die sie dahingestellt haben.
Ich weiß es noch, in der Firma, wo ich ganz am Anfang gearbeitet habe bei dem Provider,
da war in dem offiziellen Anpreisungsmaterial, waren auch alles Models und auch professionelle Fotografen,
die das gemacht haben, aber so getan haben, also als Mitarbeiter von der Firma.
Ich will zur Polizei. Mit Abitur Fachhochschulmaß als Sp...
Oh ja, natürlich. Das ist genau das Richtige für mich.
Was ist denn die Wachpolizei?
Ist das jetzt wirklich relevant, was ich irgendwann mal für einen Abschluss gemacht habe?
Wen juckt das, dass ich vor, keine Ahnung, vor 18 Jahren mal einen Realschulabschluss gemacht habe oder so?
Prima. Ah, oder einen entsprechenden Abschluss.
Wo steht denn jetzt die Jobanzeigen?
Wir bieten Fragen, Antworten... What?
Ich check die Seite schon mal gar nicht.
Okay, wir bieten. Faires Gehalt, sichere Arbeitsverwaltung, soziales Angeschränk.
Wollt ihr mich veräppeln?
Das ist für die Ausbildung. Haben die nicht irgendwas Normales?
Ich meine, die brauchen doch auch Leute, die Software entwickeln. Die müssen doch keine Polizisten sein.
Haben die nicht normale Jobs?
Was machen dann externe Unternehmen?
Ja, da kann ich jetzt nichts zu sagen. Ich finde das irgendwie verwirrend.
Okay, was auch immer. Das verwirrt mich schon so. Ich wüsste gar nicht, wo ich da anfangen soll, wenn ich da hin will.
Mindestgröße 155. Ist das nicht diskriminierend, wenn man kleiner ist? Da ist gleich die Anzeige raus.
Ja, habe ich knapp, 155.
EU-Bürger gelten die gleichen Voraussetzungen?
Höchst aller... Oh, Leute.
Das wird eng. Das wird eng. Habe ich nicht mal lang Zeit.
Habe ich nicht mal lang Zeit.
Gibt es auch eine Maxgröße? Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Zum Übungstest. Okay. Oh Leute, ich muss jetzt offclimb. Zum Übungstest.
Was? Wenn die Uhrzeit... Okay, das machen wir das nächste Mal, oder? Was, was?
Wenn die Uhrzeit der anzuklickenden Uhr 1 oder 3 Stunden nach der vergangenen Uhr angezählt, muss die Uhr doppelt angeklickt werden.
Was? Oh, das ist mir zu big brain für kurz bevor ich ins Bett gehe. Das mache ich jetzt nicht.
Das mache ich jetzt nicht.
Oh, die Telekom-Seite ist weg.
Das im Ort haben. Ja, hat er, hat er. Hätte mich auch gewonnen, wenn ich...
Vielleicht morgen schon wieder. Ich hoffe es mal zumindest. Bis denn. See you.
Oh, die Telekom-Seite ist weg.